Do I sound okay?
Do I look okay?
Like I'm such a mess right now.
Hello, hello.
Any echo?
Is it echoey?
Is it better?
Oh, I sound.
Okay, no echo.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, okay.
I sound the same.
Okay.
So I got, oh my God, I got soundproofing done.
So, um, that's why I had to, um, I had to push back a little
bit.
little bit so well it was not more than a little bit but I
got soundproofing done um in my office so um that's why I
had to push it back because it did take a while so that
means if I get a noise like we had we had this thing where
it's like this little rectangular thing and there's like a
little fluffy mic thing where it checks like the decibel of
um of like oh it's a little bit of echo don't worry I'll
just throw some I'll just grab a buy a carpet or something
by a rug or something um so so you know like those like
things that uh you can check how loud you are the decibel
thing so if i get a noise complaint no no i don't know
they're like right up to my door or so they're either the it
might have been like a goddamn plot twist and like um and my
the people that were actually complaining was like my my
like downstairs neighbor or some shit like i don't at that
point because I can't obviously I can't soundproof the floor
so like if I get a noise complaint uh from somebody it had
it's like a plot shows it's actually my downstairs neighbor
um it was never it wasn't even my next door neighbor it was
actually my downstairs neighbor like so so if that's the
case then I'm fucked uh so yes I finally got soundproof done
um So that means I will be able to, I will be able to do my
5 a.m.
streams, I hope.
I hope.
But also, I was struggling a bit because I actually broke my
monitor.
I broke one of my monitors.
So I'm working with two monitors for today.
But don't worry, I do have another monitor.
I do have an Xpair third monitor for just in case the
monitor.
breaks um it was like it was very unfortunate um i think i
asked i was i had to like um sorry i'm like my my mind is so
frazzled right now so i can't do words right now i can't
like fucking i also hit okay guys don't be too don't be like
are you okay like do you think i was like don't you please
also might have hit my head a little bit um the top of my
head a little bit because i hit I bumped my head into
something but I'm okay I think I'm okay
I'm okay because I was like try okay so what happened was I
was trying to take my monitor I was trying to well not my
monitor I was trying to like connect something to the back
of my desk and then I hit my um I hit the uh the corner the
monitor like hit my the top of my head because I was trying
to unplug something um that's not why it broke though that's
not I don't know maybe that's why i broke because my head
was just so fucking solid um um anyway so uh so my monitor
can't turn on anymore it turns on but you know like the fail
safe where it would like automatically turn off right away
so so uh so whenever i try to turn the monitor on it just
goes and then it just turns off right away like i don't
fucking know what to do so we're running on two monitors
right now until like i get my third monitor plugged back in
uh so yep that's really it it's not i don't know i tried i
was like maybe it's the plugs maybe it's like the cable i
tried like three different cables it's none of it worked so
um i think it i don't know maybe it's something inside
fucked up because it just instantly turns off on itself so i
do have another I have another monitor right now as my main
monitor so um it's very weird because it's a it's different
from my usual monitor uh because at first it was like oh do
you want to run it the recommended resolution which was like
3000 or some shit and I was like sure and I clicked on the
3000 and um and then like everything enlarged you guys were
like what the fuck do you mean dokey okay so and all my
stuff on my OBS so I'll show you guys what I mean so um
obviously the oh wait what okay there you go obviously this
is the recommended resolution that they wanted me to put in
and then where did I go where did I go on the OBS but then
if I put on the one below that um I get
So, I don't want to, I don't know, I can't be bothered
resizing all, because I actually have to resize everything
if I want to, if I want to do the recommended resolution.
And I can't be bothered.
I'm so used to what everything looks like.
So, you know, like, I don't know, it fucks with me if like
one thing changes, like that size wise, or like if I'm like
a little bit to the left, it like fucks with me a lot.
where I was for so long that like I just don't like change I
just don't like change change is bad Anthony thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you peak v2 replace peak game
I'm gonna love this eating thank you the super chat thank
you thank you uh damn that noggin is dense hollow but dense
blue to damn my hair up thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you um so I don't know I don't there's so many
things I'm all over the place right now I had to wake up so
early too for the soundproofing and stuff so I got the
consultation for sound like the quotes and consultation the
day before and I also had to wake up super early for that
and they're like we can do it get it done tomorrow I was
like sweet and then and then obviously I have to wake up
super early again to have them do the soundproofing and
everything so I'm all over the place right now I'm not I'm
not mentally there and I also hit my head too like I'm okay
I'm okay um I'm okay guys, don't worry But yeah, so So I'm
just like all over the place By the way, some people were
like Is she gonna play the censored or the non-censored
Version of this patch So the thing is No, there's no bump I
like touched the top of my head And there's no like, it's
not like you know there's no bump on my head so i think i'm
okay um but anyway so apparently there is a censored and a
non-censored version and then um i asked one of my friends
who's like fucking obsessed with dispatch right now because
i was like okay how bad is non-censored and then they were
like oh yeah at the beginning like i was like okay do i see
an actual penis because i That's fine, but I need a no, do I
see?
Is it just there?
Because that's when YouTube's like, no, no, no.
Because boobs, for some reason, boobs, because I don't know
if you guys know this on YouTube, but it allows you to see
certain nudity because they'll just be like, it's
educational or it's just part of the game.
But the moment there's a dick, that's when YouTube's like,
no.
Peepies are not allowed.
So, so I'm like, okay, how bad is it?
So, because apparently dicks aren't educational.
So, so my friend was like, showed me a clip of the first, I
guess, like 20 seconds, like the intro, where you see the
back of the peepie.
And I was like, that's not bad.
wet like it's these and then my friend was like oh yeah no
that's not the worst part no it shows the full-on pee-pee
later on i'm like oh okay that's bad that's bad guys we the
thing is i can't have another video get striped r18 guys you
know what happens um uh but no the thing is the thing is i'm
pretty sure i don't know jacksepticeye's rod might be r18
because you know what striped as R18, my Garfield, sorry,
Docafield, Jim, don't come after me.
It's a parody.
My Docafield Halloween stream got marked as R18.
So I can't do it again.
Because if you have too many streams marked as R18, YouTube
actually fucks with your algorithm.
So we can't do that again.
I don't want down on me um so i'm pretty sure like i think
get away with this on twitch but like on youtube like i
don't think i can get away with it uh but uh but i think i
don't know if jack's vibe yeah jack i'm tight with him like
that i caught him by his first name uh i don't know if jack
septica's uh stream of uh of dispatch um was marked as r.n
18.
I'm not sure.
Can anyone vouch?
Sorry, my bro Sean.
Oh yeah.
God, I'm sorry.
Sean, I forgot.
His name isn't Jack.
He likes it when we call him Jack.
So is his stream or video?
I don't know if he does the let's play.
Marked R 18 because I'm not bad dealing with that.
I'm not dealing with r18 guys it is but i also think i also
think he got away with he gets away with it because you know
um i also oh okay it's a video okay i also think he gets
away with it because he's literally like og youtube and he's
part of the game and i think if i try to stream non-censored
um i don't know how You take me.
He is a bigger streamer.
I don't think I matter to YouTube.
There's birds and bees.
Thank you.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Other than that, I have no idea what Dispatch really is.
I've heard people saying that it's sort of like Telltale.
It's like a Telltale game, so it's just watching cutscenes
and walking around, which is great.
I don't have to do much.
with extra steps so that's cool that's fine i think i don't
know if i'm gonna do all the way till the end um uh so yeah
and apparently it's made by telltale devs too so the only
also the other thing that i know about this batch is um you
mean temporary planet but you plan forever i've been saying
that like like at least once a day that's like that's my new
That's my vocal stim.
It's so good.
I just love how she's like, bitch, you plan forever.
I don't even know the context.
I just love like the delivery for that.
It's just so fucking good.
I don't even know what's going on.
I'm just like, bitch, you plan forever.
And I just keep saying that.
I don't know.
I would say it randomly too.
I would just be like, I'd just be whacking daddy.
I'd be like, fuck you be temporary, blinded, bitch, you plan
forever.
just by myself just it's just it rolls off the tugs so well
it's my new brain ride like
yeah so um like it's just i don't know it i just love i
don't know i just fucking love that that line is the
delivery is just that good uh i'm actually brainrider yeah i
thought you were addicted to ira gotcha papa smirk thank you
for this super chat thank you thank you not in the expense
of my job this is my career i can't i can't get my channel
like this is what shuts my channel down like a random pp uh
simple minded thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you joki think of the possibilities 18 plus hell yeah let's
go thank you the super chat thank you thank you anyway so
that is all the things I know about this patch, so, uh,
sorry, I apologize for starting late today, um, but, you
know, I finally got soundproofing, I went through a lot of
technical difficulties, but, you know, I finally got
soundproofing, though, so, like, you know, good for future
streams, at least, yeah, um, um, so, yeah, we're just gonna,
we're gonna try it out today, I don't know if I'm gonna do,
um, do all the episodes, I looked up that, you know, it's
like eight hours long and I don't know if I'm ready for an
eight hour playthrough For today, so we'll see if we get to
episode four and then I'm like, you know what I'm ready Then
then we'll maybe we'll do eight hours So we'll see if I
we'll see we'll see anyway Also another reason why I want to
play this game is for man bat for furry of the he is the he
is the wild the wild dark horse for the furry of the year
contender uh for those who don't know the context so every
year there so for those who need context don't worry i
explained this before on the batman stream which was very
appropriate uh let me pull up the year they would every year
um they would select one furry for the hot furry of the year
uh and right now it is between man bat and and i don't
remember it's another wolf it's it's it's another wolf i
don't fucking know so apparently man bat Charlie, Boys
Critical, is like the one to end the cycle, the wolf cycle.
And everyone's trying to figure out who is going to be 2025
Fury of the Year.
Will it be another dog?
Or will it be a bat?
The Raid of Wolf.
Will the Raid of Wolfmen end this year?
you with the super chat thank you thank you so we're gonna
find out if the cycle will end so i vote for charlie's
persona so that's the other thing i know about um about this
fact the craziest thing is that i knew about man bad because
i saw this pn because i saw that viral tweet on twitter
being like please end the wolf cycle We must vote for ManBat
to be this year's furry of the year.
And that's how I knew about ManBat.
And I was like, wait, that guy's from this batch out.
That's the only reason why I knew about ManBat.
It's like, break the cycle.
Damn, the sonar situation is crazy, guys.
I also love all the videos.
I love Spineapples.
If you guys know who Spineapple is, she's like a really
famous animator for TF2 before.
Like she would make like lots of amazing, dumb, funny Team
Fortress 2 animations.
And then she did like one for where she like basically took
like moist critical clips and then like animated to like the
Mechamac situation.
It's crazy.
It's so good.
I'll link it to you guys who doesn't want to see it.
Spine, I love Spineapples.
i love her uh her animation i used to watch that shit like
young here you go for those who want to watch the video i
love this video but let me make sure that uh all right here
you go that animation is so funny if anyone wants to check
it out um takado thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you it's my birthday weekend and we got doki dispatch
always a good time watching doki playing a superhero related
game especially because it would change based on her
decisions.
Do you think I can get a quick happy birthday?
Of course you can.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Jakarta.
Yeah, happy birthday.
Yeah, yippee.
All right, guys, let's play some Dispatch.
Oh, God, it's so weird having two monitors right now.
All right, I got to move this to my...
Oh, my God.
Okay, this is so weird.
I got to figure out how to...
I have to move all of this.
All right.
Thing is, I'll be changing this monitor, the main monitor,
to a different monitor again, too.
So it's going to be all over the place.
All right.
Don't block my dispatch.
Dispatch.
All right.
This is my, uh, Doki is my blonde blazer.
Who's blonde blazer?
I'm definitely going to make the worst choices ever, and
you're all going to yell at me.
I can feel it.
Because, like, whenever I make choices, I'm going to.
I'm like, what's the funniest choice?
Not the, what's the funniest choice out there?
Not the one that makes the most sense or like trying to be
about empathy or some shit.
Who the fuck cares about that?
I have to be a good person in real life, okay?
Like, why would I be a good person in a video game?
That's what real life is for.
It's video games for me to do the things I'm not supposed to
do in real life This is gonna be good Sombard, thank you for
the super chat Thank you, thank you It's rape lets my
choosest thoughts go wild Because there's no consequences
Alright I hope any of my sound guide people are alive I did
start a little late than usual Alright settings okay quick
time events unlimited hacking attempts language English okay
we gotta get subtitles in or on speaker's name yes please I
might forget who they are uh I need background no I don't
need it uh replaced licensed music we don't care about
profanity I need visual censorship though like other than
haha We, well, we don't care about all, I don't care about
like, like licensed music, at best they take my
monetization, but like visual censorship, I ain't getting
like R18 here.
Nathan and Ordoonite, welcome to Tomato Farm, welcome, well,
yeah, PP deny, we're denying the PPs.
We're, we draw the line with that, we get that out of here.
all right play all right nice that's like yeah that's basic
oh wait maybe maybe we should have a little bit of a
background actually yeah actually we'll look at we'll fuck
it we can sort of read that all right okay visual yep
everything is good yep this all looks good all right
cinematic interactive is he swiping left like i don't know
what you're okay we'll do be part oh yeah be part of the
action yeah of course like we're not watching a movie here i
mean technically we're half watching a movie but this is
apparently um this is apparently uh uh made have the some of
the same devs as uh telltale people so that's why it feels
very like telltale you guys were
collaboration with critical oh critical row collaborated on
this obviously i love him he's my dad okay what does that
mean do you say what that's me right i'm the main character
when you add obviously it feels a little less obvious so
i'll ask again how do you really yeah i was gonna say is
matt mercer in this it's as if maybe it's a little more
complicated then you feel i didn't he's
look he's gone yeah who the fuck cares oh game needs up
these okay let me up the game a little bit all right let me
know this is better he's fucking dead that's the most gone
you can be just so sensitive listen if i didn't love him we
wouldn't be here right we don't have to get end of it no oh
wait i'm bleeding why am i bleeding bro why the fuck is my
dog licking my nose blood shit my nose is bleeding thought i
was getting emotionally snotty no it's probably from when i
bit more oh shit what i was like oh my god am i okay i get
concussion okay more uppies don't worry i got you yeah
thanks for reminding me so here's what's gonna happen he's
Letting down.
Yeah, I noticed that.
What?
The FPS guy?
Just turn it on Twitch.
Soothing good.
Wait, am I a superhero?
I was like, the Stroud guy on Twitch?
I'm not telling you shit, you fucking loser.
See, this is more like how I thought this would be.
Is it still super quiet?
Bro, Stroud kills?
i know he does in game but all right 100 all right oh
dialogue boost okay how about that that should work i knew
it i knew i knew that he was his aim was way too good guys
like killed your father i hope he fucking spanks your little
daddy as you bitch ass yeah you hear me are we outside windy
up here tonight why are we outside am i a good person smells
like outside Oh shit I have neighbors use your inside voice
and just tell me where shroud is.
Okay.
Okay, uh steel steel mill the well and the well and steel
works Okay, you sure about that?
Yes, please.
It's all I know stop screaming.
I want to get Batman do stuff like this Hey, I will pull you
up if you quiet the fuck down.
Oh shit Okay, you don't bite the hat of someone that's
carrying you then him drop fuck it Sir, if you want
something to scream about...
You already gave me the intel, right?
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Goodbye.
Yay.
Oh, he's alive?
Oh, shit.
Hey, I ruined a perfectly good mattress to make sure you
didn't die.
Okay, you're welcome.
Okay, to be fair, he already gave me the information so that
I don't need to keep him alive.
Well, maybe a superhero is killed.
We won't get a lot of villains.
Like, that's all I'm saying.
Maybe we'll have less villains if we started killing
villains.
How is he going to remember that?
I technically saved his life.
I put him in a mattress.
Bring the music down.
Okay.
I'll bring the music down.
Cinematic music.
I'll put it at 90.
I might...
Do I even have superpowers or I'm just like...
Do I just built this mecha suit for myself?
No need for Arkham.
You got super jokie bird getting rid of all the super
villains.
Exactly!
Jakarta.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
What happens if I don't do my quick time event?
Okay, I...
Jesus Christ, we're doom scrolling right now.
Like...
I'm like, is this necessary?
Like, Atoki, please.
Am I just Iron Man?
All I'm saying is that...
My game crashed.
Okay, well, I found out apparently if you don't do your
quick time event, you're...
dispatch crashes okay okay all right i guess we go back in i
who would have thought it couldn't do that's your answer
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you my best
friend was boomed by a crazy avian bounty hunter in front of
me to do super villain numbers the first thing i'm doing is
making that my super villain origin no i have to oh my god
Okay.
All right.
Here we go again.
It's just when you add obviously, it feels a little less
obvious.
So I'll ask again.
I'll ask again.
All right.
Okay.
So maybe it's a little more complicated.
I mean, I could have asked something new.
It's completely understandable.
I could skip it in the scene select.
It didn't let me.
Look, he's gone.
That's a bit of an understatement.
Yeah.
I can't skip it.
Oh, so.
Well, he's more than.
again it's like i never dropped him the most gone just so
sensitive listen if i didn't love him we wouldn't be here
right we don't have to get into it oh wait he was trying to
give me a therapy session too man who killed him if i didn't
love him why would i be doing any of this oh my nose is
bleeding thought i was getting yeah twice to know that i
don't regret it
here's what's gonna happen i'm gonna hang you off the side
of this building and you're gonna tell me yeah just to show
you guys i i still i don't regret it come on i thought we
were having a breakthrough hey we did you know we're being a
real piece of you're pretty easy to talk to but the only oh
yeah i found out on twitter apparently um none of all the
videos are pre-rendered um they're all pre-rendered so none
of the models are in any of the files and all the gooners
were like so depressed
they couldn't get the models so all the gooners were still
sad they're like what's the point use your inside voice and
just tell me we're that's messed up all i'm saying is
gooners make
Llewellyn's deal works, okay?
Fuck.
You sure about that?
Yes, please.
That's all I know.
Stop screaming.
God damn it.
Help, help.
Hey, hey, hey.
I will pull you up.
Sam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Paying on the super chat.
Game was like, okay, if you don't want to play the game,
then there won't be a game for you to play.
I doomed scroll too far.
No, no, no, no, no.
Of course.
Of course I'll still drop him.
I ruined a perfectly good mattress to make sure you didn't
die.
Okay.
That's crazy that I didn't realize that the main character
is voiced by Jesse.
Sorry, what's his real name?
I don't even remember.
Because it sort of sounds like him, but also does not sound
like him.
Yeah, Aaron Paul.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, I was gonna up the volume a little bit more.
Alright, let me know if that's better.
Jesse, we need a dispatch.
Yeah, it's pretty good.
I didn't like him in Invincible.
I think his voice acting in Invincible was, like, pretty
dull.
Fun.
Yeah, he was the Pyreplex.
I wasn't, like, a fan of his voice acting in Pyreplex.
all
right sorry no more doom scrolling he was really good in
bojack yeah apparently i can't doom scroll anymore
oh shit what happens if i don't still did it still got it
thanks game i think they just didn't animate a different
scene for it I mean, it still worked.
What happens to that, I guess?
Will I get shot?
Oh, shit!
Oh, fuck!
I should have hit back!
I should have defended myself!
I thought he would defend himself for me.
So, fight back!
I thought the game would help me.
I guess it's time to make new models on Blender.
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
My actions have consequences?
No way.
Oh, WSD.
Am I supposed to go?
Time to finish this.
Hello.
Input code.
Oh, this is easy.
101 baby's first hack oh and the swish okay there you go
some notes allowed all right next one where do i go oh i
have to rehack this okay oh my god this is so easy there you
go oh i grab this just one more
back god damn it i knew i would have done the bottom first
god i'm so good at hacking this clearly reflects irl hacking
too what am i waiting for waiting on final breach where is
it
breaching i what
am i waiting oh shit the mouse button is above me.
I'm doing it.
Sorry, I was looking down.
I was looking down.
Hacking is so easy, guys.
It's so easy.
Can I die in this game?
Like, if I fail too many quick time events?
It's over, shroud.
Can I get a copy of that video when we're through here?
Because it's over, Shroud.
That's right.
It would be nice to watch that back at a different angle.
That's right, Shroud.
I'm aiming for you.
I'll be the next FPS streamer.
Where the fuck is Shroud?
Yeah, where is Shroud?
Is he still streaming Arc Raiders?
After a conversation, I asked him about your dad.
Fun little tidbit.
He was very well hydrated.
right after shroud shot him in the chest your dad pissed his
pants bet you didn't know that huh so after that yes are you
too busy playing our creators right now still at enough time
to know how absolutely he was and just pissed himself like a
little it was like so much hunter stomping dad was wearing
shorts so just kept i get it oh oh like foot oh i should
have stomped him
If I knew...
Oh, this is the Mecha Man situation.
Wait, I'm Mecha Man.
I understand now.
Sorry, I didn't think I didn't need to waste a perfectly
good mattress to break your fall.
Perfectly good.
Oh, shit.
Was already in the dumpster.
Can we just skip to the part where you...
How is he alive?
Oh, God!
Oh, there's the PPC.
Oh,
there you go.
Okay, there.
There it is.
Clever super villain there.
You can call me toxic.
Okay.
There it is.
So many levels for you.
Yeah, no shit.
That's the point.
That is.
Trout's augments are pretty good when Normie's.
Oh, yeah, no.
Yeah, no.
No, we will not be safe on YouTube.
If I...
Yeah, no.
We would have not been saved.
It's just...
Oh, shit.
Okay, wait, I got help.
I got to help him out, bro.
Thank God we're just sick.
That's right.
Why don't I just rip it off?
I mean, it's just swinging there.
It's just... Yeah, why don't I...
Why don't I just...
Just rip it up.
Fuck.
Don't let it hit you.
Oh my god, you're right, I could- Oh shit!
You're right, I could have just like swung it around too.
That's against the man goat.
Just start using it as a rope.
Figures.
All right.
Piece of shit.
Oh, man.
This fight scene is pretty good, though.
Wait, it's just Jello.
Do all of them just let it swing around like that?
Like...
Oh, this way.
Black sensor clock.
Oh, shit!
Alright.
Bye-bye.
Yay!
One less super villain.
Oh, shit.
Where's his dick?
See, he lives, guys.
Bro, why is it, like, just in my
Oh no, wait, it's burning my mecha suit.
Oh shit.
Wait, what am I doing?
I'm rebooting?
I'm alt F4ing?
Alt F4 and reboot.
Oh, this is looking bad.
Jakarta, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I'm a barrier?
Wait, would I have died if I didn't do that?
I'm overclocking.
Don't worry.
Shroud!
He came back from Arc Raiders!
Hey, Shroud!
Welcome back!
So, what do you got left on them shields?
I said 40% He stopped his stream You're down to 28 And he is
not wrong about these things Good news, buddy Shroud says he
just wants the Astral Pulse Which we all know Isn't really
yours anyway Unless he missed the opportunity To not get
Shrouded Oh, there he is Your dad killer Okay System check.
Calculate the damage per second hitting shields.
Then tell me how many seconds I need to divert Astral Pulse
energy to Raka boosters.
Animation's really good.
Also, sound guy.
I hope all the sound is good so far.
Pulse power to the boosters.
It won't work.
This is a limited time offer, dude.
What's up?
Ignore him.
Villains always lie.
Oh, shit.
No.
I don't give a fuck, okay?
here.
He says you're not calculating that ship stuck to your leg,
dumbass.
Nuh-uh.
Fuck it.
I wanted to hear more of the dialogue.
All going to plan.
Now get out of there, baby.
See, everything's fine.
Come on.
See, I told you he was lying.
Okay, But why censor the ass?
This ass is fine.
Ass is technically PG.
Yeah!
Pulse status.
Stable.
Foreign device detected.
Oh?
Oh, do I have a tracker?
Or like...
Oh.
He don't get to have cake and eat it too.
Stop fear!
That's fine.
He's a mean character.
Dispatch.
But that Mega Man situation was crazy though.
Oh hey, are we watching TikTok now?
It was just over four months ago that images like this were
recorded across the Southland.
Videos flooded social media and our newsroom showing what
many thought to be.
the death of mecha man again again for near oh like us his
dad man has protected los angeles built by an ordinary
civilian with no superpowers this first suit was dubbed by
some fans as mecha man prime that's his dad three
generations of pilot oh that's his grandpa secret have given
everything to protect this community including their lives
after the tragic passing of prime the next mecha man astral
teamed up with a star-studded superhero group known as the
brave brigade leading to its legacy legacy position after
years of loyal service tragedy loyal nepotism when shroud a
former brave brigade member turned villain killed the pilot
of mecha man in cold blood but yet again as hope was lost a
third generation of mecha man emerged a mecha man for the
modern era a bulwark against organized crime in in the
greater Los Angeles area until...
Earlier today, Mecca had broke his silence.
And addressed the bloodline.
Wait, he's fine.
He didn't die.
He's literally right here.
Just build another suit.
I had speculation to rest.
The suit has been damaged beyond my ability to repair, so I
will be stepping back from superhero...
But just build another suit!
What do you mean?
Does this mean you're finished?
Can you repair your suit?
What's next for Mecca Man?
Yeah!
That means your career is over.
How badly were you hurt?
One at a time, please.
Ashley Rynes, San Pedro Daly?
Do you have anything to say to your fans?
The public outpouring, the vigils, a lot of them were
worried you wouldn't wake up.
I suppose I want them to know I did my best.
I worked as long as I could, as hard as I could.
Oh, he's so fucking depressed.
That's all anyone can do.
Next question.
Chris Stratton.
Torrent's Tribune.
Does this mean you're retiring as Mecha Man?
Word on the street is, you're Dunzo.
Are you a hundred years old?
Why are you talking like that?
Answer the question, buddy boy.
Are you retiring?
My readers need the skinny, and I aim to deliver.
No comment.
I'm not looking to comment on that just yet.
That's the only skinny I can give you.
You deserve my comment after that.
You saw me, no comment.
Just one more.
Heads on for you.
Charles Kingsley, South Bay Signal.
So, Shroud kills your father, goes to jail 50 years, breaks
out, and immediately dupes you into a trap where he destroys
the Mecha Man suit and puts you in a coma for months.
I can't get over the fact that his name is Shroud.
I was like, Shroud, didn't I?
Holy fuck, Shroud.
Shroud did what?
Why didn't Shroud kill you?
You haven't been conscious for months.
It'd be easy money taking you out.
Bro, I'm sure I got real toxic.
He got both.
I'm not sure I mattered much.
You're unimportant.
Which leads me to my next question.
Most heroes avenge their family.
You did the opposite.
What did I do?
You killed their legacy.
What?
How disappointed would your dad be if he were here right
now?
I'm still alive.
I could come back.
I'll attack.
Fuck you.
You know what?
Who cares?
I'm retired anyway.
My reputation is...
Oh, yeah!
Yeah!
On international news, dude?
Of course.
But there's two issues there.
He clearly has nothing left.
Exactly.
I have nothing left to lose.
I'm technically retired.
Yay, alcoholism, too.
No one was stepping in.
Bro, I wouldn't fucking have.
Like I said, I have nothing to lose here.
That's...
Hey, I was watching that.
Bro, I'm broke.
I have no TV.
Are you assholes?
I was fucking watching that.
Hey, who are you calling assholes, asshole?
I'll handle this idiot.
Keep loading.
We're out of here in 30.
And who the fuck are you?
yeah you go go fucking hobo ranger someone with nothing to
lose i beat up a reporter i can beat you up too which is
probably bad news for you well what nothing you have you're
about to lose again whatever the case i'm enough to deal
with i'm a hobo ranger god damn it look you're hurt you're
not thinking straight wait which one okay right Someone who
knows which hand every punch is coming.
I'm a punch with my right.
That's right.
Oh shit That's right.
I still have legs though
Oh shit, I can't continue my legacy
What the
Fight back.
Eh.
I did it, guys.
That guy I threw.
He landed on the roof, right?
Yeah, totally.
Hi, I'm Blomblazer.
I work over at Superhero Dispatch Network.
Also, I can't believe it!
You can't romance the man back!
You know who you are.
He's 100% straight!
That's also the only deal breaker for me.
I'm just a corporate hero for hire.
You're the real deal.
I found that out as well.
I'm so sad.
I don't think infamous is the same as famous, but...
Oh, God.
Your arm.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, that's gross.
Yeah.
Divide 0% upshade.
That's your S2 thing in the Super Chat thing.
Thank you.
Usually dislocates the other way.
Have you done this before?
but have you done this before because maybe oh god okay wow
that's uh that's okay thank you one of them is on that roof
yeah mecha man mecha man you look like you can only romance
two people and they're both women what makes you say that i
could just romance all of them you know i have nothing to
lose.
I should be able to romance any character.
I didn't even realize it.
I should be able to hook up with everyone.
So true.
Where's my hair around?
I'm thinking about the back of the ship.
I don't really make jokes like that.
I think Vizzy's rubbing off on me.
Who?
Someone I work with.
It's...
Yeah.
what this feels like a challenge
that feels like a challenge yeah no do it chug chug chug
love is in the air don't worry about keeping up something to
do with the powers it actually be like a romance shroud my
daddy killer very sad sentence hey you should give yourself
more credit to do what you did for as long as you did
especially without superpowers not true what do you call
this oh god i can fix that one for you too no thanks i like
this one thank you yeah and to toxic yeah enemies to lovers
exactly so this game would have been perfect if i could
romance everyone hundreds of thousands of millions so you'll
understand when the check comes you're serious millions yeah
i basically burned through my entire inheritance keeping it
going last couple years have just been duct tape and sheer
determination what like what is this job what did he said to
sacrifice everything to be a superhero to the point of
financial oh my god it's like batman if he's broke hardship
but ruin was the first man if he had no money you must be
completely it's like i've missed the only thing i'm good at
this is what i'm good at now that's a sad sentence come on
that can't be true i guess it could be true so are you he's
broke man uh yeah yeah i should probably switch into water
good because i was hoping after some drinks to loosen you up
i could learn a little more about you And if all that went
well, this is why he didn't invest, guys.
He fucked up.
You always have, like, passive income.
I'm just trying to figure out if this is a fit or not.
You know, then it's just a matter of picking the right
moment.
A bar?
Well, propositions late at night in a bar can go any number
of ways.
That's actually...
What's that?
This is, like, pure alcohol.
It's not like alcohol.
It is.
Alcohol I know because you spit it directly and damn that's
so hot guys that's water that see how it is guys I have such
good risk hard liquor from a pint glass actually.
I usually just drink it straight from the bottle, but I
thought she's an alcoholic
I'm gonna go clean up she likes it guys see she likes this
fine.
She likes it right back She likes when I'm lesser than her
Yeah, she's into it.
The more pathetic I am, the more I'm attracted to her.
Don't you watch the news?
This is a superhero bar.
Oh, wow.
Are you a superhero?
That's so cool.
Is this your power?
You're like, you know, people obvious shit guy.
Well, you're really going to ugly.
You don't remember me.
wait it's coming back to me hold on yeah it's coming back
doctor oh wait sunglasses at night you are sunglasses
indoors at night guy your superpowers they were able to let
everyone know in the room that you're a douchebag because
you should literally never do that unless you're at the
final table of the world series of poker but even then if
you win you're still a fucking loser
I'm gonna lose.
Sorry, I choked on my spit.
Oh, mega bitch.
Yeah, no shit.
You're flamb.
And the flame.
And my skin does not burn.
I am flamb.
And you...
Wait, oh shit, I do remember you're that shitty villain I
busted up.
Wait, he's a villain?
As I literally just said.
I am flamb.
You can just do that?
you have a criminal record anymore so you need to get the
fuck out of here water we can do this the easy way there we
go there easy way right i've been waiting alone guys i know
what alcohol does i'm not that stupid i guys guys i know
what the fuck alcohol does to fire holy shoy Yeah, no one
there.
Then you gotta change your job, bro.
What song is that?
Bro, I wanted to live.
Your mouth.
It's whistling.
Come on, we should get you to a hospital.
No, Coupe.
Fucking guy needs a dentist.
Oh, hey, there's Jack.
Sorry, shy.
Should be able to reattach it.
Punch up.
Teeth don't work that way.
You're thinking of fingers and dicks.
You know what?
Give it a shot.
Oh, is it funnier with alcohol?
Do I not live?
Get the fuck out of here.
I get it.
Can you just tell Blazer I'm outside?
Oh.
Out!
Relax, I'm leaving.
Wouldn't alcohol hurt me more?
Like...
Hey, I couldn't find you.
It's cool.
I was just admiring the art on this dumpster.
Can't tell why anyone would put those words together.
All right.
Why are you holding drinks?
Nightcap?
You're not.
God, she's an alcoholic.
Actually, according to the bartender, that's exactly what
you are.
What happened in there?
I walk out and the bartender's pissed.
The whole energy is awkward.
And I almost rolled the heck out of my ankle on this
slippery floor.
The guy fell down.
It was pretty funny.
Yeah, it's crazy.
This guy just fell down.
She got me free alcohol.
The guy fell down.
Usually you're supposed to get her alcohol.
Does that not sound convincing?
Are they both for herself?
Hold these.
I know a place.
you're stung it's a little out there easier if we fly whoa
oh she's carrying me too damn no she's definitely the top in
this relationship oh that's pretty okay That's beautiful.
Uppies, we got upies.
Yay!
Yeah, she's, yeah, she's the muscle, mommy.
This is like LA propaganda.
To sit on it.
Oh, yeah.
That would have been cool.
Oh, no.
Phenomenal.
Because you can see it.
And it looks like there's a couple up there already.
I really needed this.
All of this has been pretty overwhelming, you know.
Yeah, where's the traffic?
Often and I think I really needed this, so thank you for
bringing me out.
I had a really great time.
Don't you worry about it, Robert Robertson.
How do you know my name?
That's his name?
Robert Robertson?
Okay, I'll tell you.
But...
tell me how you ended up with yeah yeah
it happened three times there's grandpa bobby then my dad
who i called dad but everyone else called robbie and then me
robert robert i wanted to be taken seriously hmm family
tradition robbie the third they did it three times he died
in the suit before i was born That's when I took over.
There was a little inheritance and the life insurance money.
I'm so sorry.
That's smart.
I think as a superhero, you should always take life
insurance.
Just your run-of-the-mill sad superhero origin story.
The family tradition, if there is one, is dying in that
suit, which I guess I don't have to worry about anymore.
What is it?
I'm not quite drunk enough to share my origin story.
yet, but but she never said how she knew.
Definitely.
She like doxed him.
How did she know?
Bro, doxing is not a joking matter.
Yeah.
We can work with this.
What?
Kiss her.
Let's do it.
Can't, I only have two options anyway.
I gotta get what, I gotta take what I can get.
No, this I'm You took off my mask and then docks me I'm so
sorry You didn't I mean you did Okay, that is not true That
is not true Guys, we all saw She started it How did I
fumble?
She faded me Unprofessional She literally talks to me I'm
actually here on a business how I know your name the
proposition I mentioned right before you spit in my mouth
still mortified about that and then she got me alcohol do
you remember a superhero named trackstar remember of course
he's like family that I haven't talked to in a while but
what about him I work with him at SDN he recommended you
mentioned that he worked she put my head on my chin what am
I supposed to play with that it was kind of my babysitter
for a while how's he doing he's doing great he's he's why
i'm here robert i would like to make you an offer in
exchange for dispatching and mentoring some of our rookie
heroes sdn can make you mecca man again oh wait i get a job
thanks no more paying out of pocket for repairs support
staff the whole this is an interview so this was like some
sort of interview i was worried that you might be crazy
unstable damaged unfit i did beat up a reporter on live
television but like all superheroes do that it's a big
investment it'll take considerable time and money to get the
suit repaired and the missing pieces replaced plenty of time
to learn how to dispatch nine to five job let's go oh my god
dispatch idle job your common mistake she is just nice Thank
you.
Champion, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What do I say?
No.
And what if I say no?
Like, then I'll hate you forever.
And I'll push you off the spillboard.
Man.
That's hot.
And no one would suspect a thing.
Nope.
Not a one.
Wait, so you want me dispatching?
What's that even mean?
Roll credits, guys.
Joke you and be the first to be sent to HR.
God, thank you for the super chat.
thank you noted am i waiting or are you waiting what's going
on it was supposed to open up when i threw it to you oh
there it is pop it on this is part of the assessment that i
just leave i just i just reject the job title game over
greetings and welcome to this training simulation we may be
superheroes but we're nothing without sdn's real hero the
dispatcher so dispatcher where do we start what if i wait
what if i fail does the game just end well well it appears
we've got our first call from a subscriber i saw some scary
suspicious men last night leaving the old movie theater
you'll receive requirements to help you determine which
defend yourself against the strike the devil is fortified
okay such an array of brave heroes to How could you possibly
pick just one?
The fuck is brain, though?
This graph will show you what a hero does well and not so
well.
Okay, charisma, combat, intelligent, vigor, mobility,
charisma.
A hero with a knack for vigor and combat looks right for the
job.
That sounds like me.
Phenomoman.
Phenomoman, alright.
hero is being dispatched it's time to get to work all right
a sound approach
i will now return to sdn
when a hero returns to sdn they'll need some much needed rn
that stands for rest and relaxation oh it is thor's voice
actor we could never escape margaritas if we were i'll go
Review your hero's performance.
It always comes back.
They won't be sent out again until you do.
All right.
This is my nine to five job now.
Okay.
How did they do?
A SDN's state of the art graph.
We can see an analysis of what skills the call required.
Okay.
Let's see how well I did after responding to that
caller's...
Well, call.
There's no such thing as a perfect fit.
Use your intellect and your roster to your advantage.
Okay, so I just need to make sure I get the best fit
possible.
The more that my skills align with the needs of the job, the
more likely I am to succeed.
Okay.
That seems easy enough.
Right?
Organized criminals, often led by figurehead supervillains,
are the scourge of Southern California.
out all right we've got a potential villain hideout on the
college campus on college campus brains not brawn sdn's
diverse array of heroes can solve investigate decode a
mysterious clue okay it's investigation okay so mobility
you're not that smart
intelligent charisma mobility yeah you're not that smart i'm
gonna need to send you there be the best right i got it
there you go power knowledge is power yeah she has glasses
on
i don't need a scent too oh she did it yeah see oh shit yeah
see i did it oh nice guys we did it nice see she didn't die
The museum is doing an exhibit On this local, and he's a
guest speaker Uh, incorporate your unique Perspective?
A better city Brick by brick.
Okay, it has to be Charisma, man.
Uh, who Has, oh, nope.
I need someone With Charisma.
Oh, he Can talk.
The sweet talker.
Yeah, it has to be The sweet talker.
Yeah.
I mean, I could get two.
Doesn't really matter, right?
There you go.
Let's grab two.
Two for one.
One of your heroes needs you as their leader your heroes
will look to you make choices and follow where they it's
boring we're going to have to improvise sprinkle oh show off
your moves that's what kids like to see that's right i
assume these choices need the right skill remember each of
your hero's strengths and weaknesses.
A perfect dispatch.
You are a natural.
Imagine calling superhero.
I'm like, oh wait, I am.
I'm like the 911 dispatcher.
Oh my God, that's what's got that.
Oh my God, that's what's got dispatch.
Karen, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And Doki, and there's the phone.
Oh my God, it's like we call 911 and you get me.
How fucked are you?
A convoy of Diablo's goons They're harrying the highway
patrol.
Intercept, overwhelm, whatever.
As if traffic in this city was not bad enough.
Who is?
Speaking of traffic and going places, does SDN offer paid
time off to take vacations?
Of course.
PTO accrues at a regular rate over time.
Wait, there's paid vacation too?
As long as you discuss your schedule with your manager well
in advance.
What the fuck is a PTO?
Yeah, what the fuck is a PTO?
Okay, okay, okay.
There's a giant monster attacking.
Oh, shit.
Oh, shit, what?
Don't worry, they'll be fine.
I got time.
I don't think sending the...
Okay, um, alright, there you go.
The diabolical super villain El Diablo is attacking Los
Angeles General.
Oh, shit.
It's one of my arch nemesis.
Oh.
El Diablo.
That means the Diablo in stretch.
He must have been using the convoy ambush as a distraction.
Okay, by the time.
I can send one to each.
Oh, shit.
No, he's a...
Oh, no.
Speaking of hospitals, did you know SDN offers a robust
benefits package for all full-time employees?
Do I get dental, too?
All right, don't worry.
We can wait a little bit.
We'll put one... Oh, my God.
Okay.
I need help getting to my doctor's appointment.
Make case before... Oh, wait.
That's mobility.
All right.
Clock this.
Don't worry.
Help this grandma.
Okay.
There we go.
El Diablo.
You go in.
there all right defend oh gosh that's vigor is defend oh
gosh okay wait actually of course um who oh no okay uh um
it'll be fine i am on the way we're being helped send help
please the villains convince the goons okay sweet talker
there you go you baby anything oh damn wow wow oh wait
Check.
Oh, wait, no.
It has to be.
There you go.
We're so fine.
They're returning.
SDN values work-life balance.
When the bell rings, your shift will end very soon.
Alright, no, no, no.
Everything is fine.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
We can... Oh, no.
Everything... Oh, no.
It's okay.
Oh, my guys.
Sometimes a hero can use their talents to tip the rough up
and round the goons.
Okay, there you go.
Did we do it?
Yeah!
We saved the children!
The children are safe and sound.
Okay, that's fine.
Did we do it?
I forgot the check marks, guys.
Yay, we did it!
You crossed the road!
Okay, it's okay.
problems big and small we never ignore the people of the
city particularly the elderly speaking of retirement quick
question phenomenon yes but there are limitations how did
you you got the messages what's the point of your job it's
okay everything is fine we'll just fire him guys we'll
Call me justice.
Oh, God.
We made it just in time.
Okay.
On your mark.
This is fine.
See, I told you guys.
El Diablo's goons are running scared.
We're right on the heels of his sidekick, El Diolito.
How is this my fault?
His whole name is Sweet Talker, and somehow he didn't Sweet
Talk his way out of it.
Okay, back, survive the defeat and detain.
El Diablo.
Okay, we can wait a little bit.
We have time to wait a little bit.
Then we'll send him over.
All right.
Okay, it's fine.
You just need to rest a little bit.
All right, and then I'll send you in.
And then I'll send you in.
Excellent choice.
And then there's no way you guys can fuck this up.
It's a We just fire him We just fired Sweet talker He didn't
do his job Oh god no Oh it's 100% thank god Okay nice See it
It should be 100% at that point Oh my god Okay There's no
way Oh thank god okay Okay What can I say?
A lot, actually.
Look, see?
He did it.
Our shift is done now.
It is time for one.
We just had, like, one or two person.
Only one or two people died.
I'm going to enhance my break time with some of the snack
offerings and our break room vending machines.
Every 10 seconds, someone dies in the world.
I hope to be seeing a lot more.
So, like, you know, and don't forget to be fun now.
Just happen to be his time.
Did he just say phenomenal?
Well, looks like I'm great at this.
Yeah, I'm so good.
That's going to be bad for your negotiating position.
Expect a lengthy...
Did I drool on you?
What am I?
Some kind of emergency dispatch?
Peter, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you, babe.
It makes sense, yeah.
Meet me at the SDN offices tomorrow.
That's a date.
I'm not done saving you yet.
Bro, she can fix me.
See, guys, the more pathetic I am, the more she's into me.
She can fix me.
Every 10 seconds, someone dies.
Ira Doki, hold my beer.
Cameron, thank you.
Super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
He's a fat-ass dog.
Give him some cereal.
I'm going to make him fatter.
That's right.
at SDN are the best in the business.
I met a nice lady.
She wants to help us out.
Bro, I live like this.
Bro, you live like...
Bro, I didn't unpack...
Oh my god, he is me.
It's how he wins.
This is my house.
This is my apartment.
I'm so immersed.
I feel just like him.
Is there any after-credit scene or do I just continue?
You live like that?
I wish my apartment was that clean.
No, this is episode one.
It's episodic.
This is why I didn't play the game until all the episodes
are released because I hate episodic format.
I fucking hate the episodic format in general.
Oh, yeah, there you go.
Yeah, okay, it's a 50-50.
Very telltale like Doki Doki Thank you for the super chat
Thank you Thank you Alright next Do we all kiss?
You would See look at that I'm the majority We all saw it
Let the goon drop your success rate You perform better than
60% of the players Nice To be fair I was fucking around
though You and 21% of players attack the reporter you okay
all right i aced it guys look at that you and 53 of players
ace the tutorial bro i'm guys look i'm the one percent
jacardo they even super chat thank you thank you yeah look
at that see look at that i did i aced it i let two people
die and i'd still pass i got i got an a plus obviously those
hostages don't matter he
was gonna die anyway not today but maybe tomorrow don't keep
give into the mind control societal thank you the super chat
thank you thank you i heard there's a character in here that
looks like the arcane girl i'm gonna be late for band
practice unexpected things happen every day phenomena man
we're literally living in a town where there's super
villains someone's gonna have to to help lift the burdens
life throws at us.
Let SDN be your rock so you can rock.
SDN is not an insurance company and does not cover damages.
She's definitely not making it to ban practice.
Is SDN like a superhero union?
Hmm?
No, just the commercial.
It was weird.
Weird.
Yeah, right.
Oh, so it's like a union.
Oh my God.
even superheroes have a union?
It's a... I'm joking.
Oh, it's like a Corpo.
Oh, it's like an... Oh.
I'm a Pharma fan, you might say.
Yeah, he's phenomenal.
He seems cool.
Phenomenal even.
And quite the salesman.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, he could sell snowballs to an Eskimo.
Is it not... Not cool to say?
Snowman.
He could sell snowballs to a snow...
Oh, my God.
I'm Corpo.
Anyone made of snow.
Any color snow doesn't have to be white.
God.
Yeah.
Oh, so it's like a private security firm.
Oh, wait, that's fucked.
If I have to, like, hire someone to save me.
Just, yeah.
Okay, let me.
Wait, how do they get paid?
Do, like, the civilians they save?
Pay them?
I have so many questions.
No, I mean, yes.
But yes is more.
My powers make everything wet.
Wait, okay.
Okay.
Okay, I need a no.
Wait, they have to...
It's a subscription, please.
Guys, if you subscribe every month, it's like...
It's a monthly subscription.
Guys, if you guys don't want to fucking die, make sure to
monthly subscribe to the superhero perk.
That is...
Fuck.
Wait, that is...
I was clearly not paying too much.
No, I'm so confused.
I was like, subscribers?
Like, I was like, What do you mean subscribers?
So it's actually a private security firm.
Dude, is there any superheroes that do...
It's like a public defendant.
You know how like criminals, they are...
They have the right for a lawyer.
Are there superheroes that like, you know, do it for
charity?
Is there like public superheroes, you know?
Like you might have to wait like two to three...
Like five to ten business days.
Oh, that's what Mecca...
No wonder I was broke.
how they call me but yes i am here it was okay that makes
sense now
oh there's plan b
that's crazy a subscription bro it's like you're like
dangling off the bridge and you're like sorry you forgot to
pay for your subscription fee that i know you you missed
your payment you're mecca man i you you're dead i thought
this on the inside you uh look small or different in person
never meet your heroes kid oh i wasn't sure you'd show up oh
what what it's like health insurance with extra stuff sorry
but i i need him for something follow me
in dokey's world batman would fund wayne tech by charging
five dollars a month in protection fee but actually they
give this super chat thank you thank you guys that's why the
host is just sad what's happening right now we don't want
too many people knowing you missed the subscription former
heroes but it's better if you keep your identity a secret
we've had incidents in the past here what i remembered you
being bigger i was a little drunk listen it's gonna be great
i've never felt silly wearing this until now yeah i was
trying to imply that with the silence It worked.
Get dressed.
I also think superhero costumes are pretty silly.
Whoa, why is she watching?
Whoa!
First you won.
First you... Oh, wait.
Is this a... Yeah.
Is this an HR violation?
This might be the fastest HR violation of a new employee in
history.
Whoa!
Yeah, fucking turn around.
We didn't kiss.
Oh, shit.
It doesn't look like it, but I am flexing every muscle.
in my body right now that's looking right currently no kiss
no looking no peaking like that i i want to say again i'm
sorry about last night i regret the way i conducted myself
it was a mistake a complicated mistake i can uh go into the
details of those complications with you didn't feel like a
mistake though at least not to me well that makes one of us
oh Oh, you can turn around now.
If you want, oh, you can turn around if you want.
Just trip down in front of you.
Pro-fesh.
Are you serious?
I've lost scars.
Oh, what the?
Guys, I have.
I've got it.
Told you.
I have so much Riz.
Oh, there she is.
Arcane.
So, uh, you two fuck or what?
We kissed.
innocent like cheek innocent or tip of your dick innocent
okay oh damn first of all we did not kiss you kissed me
second of all it's none of your freaking business well who's
she cussed it must have been a good one robert this is
invisigal she is part of the phoenix program we take former
super villains such as herself and rehabilitate them to
re-enter society to use their powers for are those my
earrings well they look better on me in visigal this is
robert he'll be your dispatcher oh washed up dad bought
superhero with no superpowers can't wait his identity all of
this bro i have a six pack you see it he's still mac a man
but that can't get out and if it does i'll know who it came
from you think i want to tell people our dispatcher's a
fucking loser that makes superpowers doesn't automatically
make you a superhero that's right one with one you have to
earn the other well i'm wet i see why you like him Look at
that trip.
What does that look?
Best by Fight Club?
Bro, you have asthma.
That ain't fucking...
Tough, bro.
It's not tough when you have asthma.
And she's at the bottom.
She called herself Invisibitch when she was a villain.
Bro, she looked down.
You saw that.
Yeah, I thought Invisibelle felt kind of corny for her.
You saw her look down.
Her eyes flicked down.
Just get your shirt on, Dad Bod.
We have a six-pack.
Reminds me of the Incredibles.
But we've got what makes the real difference.
Great people.
Some of them aren't even people, and they're still great.
Oh my god, this is depressing.
Facts, scan does literally everything.
This is so depressing.
This is an actual nine-to-five office work.
I used to call it triple Ds, but I was informed that had a
different connotation.
3Ds?
Dispatching.
Documentation...
Diversity is the third.
Not in terms of priority, of course.
Yep.
We're all about diversity.
Lana works in the mailroom.
From a different galaxy altogether.
And then there's Galen.
Way back there.
Born with Superhearing.
He's from...
Oh, I want to see...
Florida!
First!
Florida's a no-brainer!
Bro!
I think she might be a little corny corporate dick meet me
in the records room when you're done if you get lost look
for the door that says records room because I think she has
a lot of hr violations
anyway thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
solely average wise everyone calling him small um i would
like to say above average what the fuck bro i almost went in
my pants hey you this robber people talking about what's up
brother my auntie named me roy but people call me roy bro
fist bro what's up bro to meet you, bruh.
The bro code.
Bro, he decided.
Like steroid?
Huh?
Yeah, no, brother.
No, no, no, no.
Cause listen, listen.
It's all natural.
They go by the name Roy.
So I think it's like, you know, we go scrap, we go ground, I
bust you up and then you know, you got Royd.
You know what I'm saying, bruh.
That's, that's what I, that's what I think.
He's still peeing?
Holy shit.
that's why they call me right like i'm on steroids but they
think i'm some kind of a juice head they think i'm not natty
no i'm just kidding i think roy's not natty no i'm just
kidding man just making jokes about your name and the it's
all right bro it's not too deep i don't care that's yeah big
guy big bladder is probably best or is that nice meeting you
roy even if it was It's like, he's like from Moana.
You want funny bugger.
Mecca, man.
What?
How did you know?
What the fuck?
Okay, so I was worried about your unwashed hand, but now I'm
worried that everyone here knows who I am.
Nah, brother.
It's Kapu.
Need to know basis and Roy need to know.
I don't want to come pick up your soup or fix them for the
SDN.
Cool.
You're gonna wash before you do that?
Nah, bro.
Bro, why is everyone doxing me?
Just touch my pants with underwear only.
I just do like this.
Can you show me again?
I don't think I got it.
Oh, you fixed our suit.
Holy shit.
Who's this freckled face?
How are you?
That's an aggressive way to greet someone.
Look at this skinny latte prick.
Your bones, kid.
You here to whip these assholes in the shape or what?
That's the idea.
Do I know you?
I'm sorry.
Why are you all tense?
What?
It's a hug, not a handjob.
We're already reminded of that Moana guy.
I'm still confused.
Oh, right.
Because I'm old as shit.
How about this?
This jog your memory?
Trackstar?
Holy shit.
I thought he was jabbing.
Why are you accepting hugs from old men you don't know?
Oh, and hey, they call me Chase around you.
Yeah, it reminds me of Maui.
Sure, right.
Yeah, Chase.
It's been what, 10, 15 years?
Has it really been that long?
out to this little piss ant when his dad passed then he got
the duck in me like he owed me money i was in a weird place
i understand kid it was tough on all of us so i can't
imagine what you went through yeah so what's up you need to
tell me why you look like black hindstein sorry i never
noticed bucker it's the powers i can move 50 times faster
than the average person but i didn't realize until it was
too late and i was aging 50 times faster when i used my
powers what that's crazy slower than frozen pissed so how
old are you yeah then how old are you really i turned 39 a
few months ago he's 39 so i guess this means you're the one
person i can't complain to about losing my suit you better
not i would resurrect then re-kill your father in front of
you if it meant i thought like he was friends with his dad
jesus chase the average
I extinguished the light from his eyes.
Was he always like this?
Yes, actually.
We joke, we laugh, we suppress our trauma.
All right, enough of this feeling shit.
Let's introduce you to your team of losers.
Our team of losers?
Now, if I'm being honest, I thought and still think we
should have canned these tuners months ago.
And you might get your wish.
Because if we don't see improvements soon, the whole program
will be scrapped.
Come zipped here.
pressure oh man bad was a harvard graduate who who will not
shut the up about being a harvard graduate oh my god i gotta
get him in also orchestrated some of the most effective
silicon okay high intention addictive variety of
embezzlement wait he's a villain that would eat you as first
after he empties a phoenix embezzlement extortion drug
possession forgery fraud money
We got to get him in.
Okay.
Flamb.
Controls the fire and the flame and his skin does not burn.
Right.
You've met him.
Didn't you ever run in with him years back?
We need that.
We need a cyber bully.
None of these are as important.
In Visigal.
Who you met.
I'm mad at that situation.
It's crazy.
I entered the program on a condition we didn't ask
questions.
That's a little suspicious now.
is really of a criminal that turns invisible and doesn't
like to answer questions what tip do you off sherlock i feel
like loner thief loner i feel like wait what is his oh bad
boy con man that's your fucking villain name that's such a
fucking stupid ass okay oh wait no okay never mind i thought
aka invisibish because it was like okay never mind you're
right this is just an app extra i was like why would if your
villain name is bad boy con man that is a shitty ass villain
here we have coupe which i recently learned is a french
ballet term that means two cut hence the knife i thought it
was cool so everybody calls it coop she was an assassin for
the mob then went independent aggravated assault extortion
first degree murder kidnapping stalking jesus true kill
count like many things about her is unknown oh nobody knows
oh but like wait she's bad at fighting but she all fucking
she's a killer how do you be bad at fighting can't kill
carnival strong man who made a deal with a sorceress she
gave him the strength of ten men his muscles grew but his
body shrunk he's got all the charming brains of a greasy
bowling ball battery parole violation public intoxication
second degree murder only second degree god you're such a
shitty villain um pain immunity all right there he is
they're shy Oh, I heard you can't romance her, so what's the
point?
Oh!
That's magic!
Wait, that's fucking magic!
Oh my god, we can't escape Marvel Rivals.
Murder is still murder.
Yeah, you can't romance her, apparently.
Sonars, NA sponsor, atheist true crime.
Assault, burglary, forgery, kidnapping.
Only second degree, guys?
Come on, do better.
He is a construct a construct.
Yeah, a bunch of dirt and mud made sentient with magic.
Oh, it's clay face I think he's lonely.
It's clay face plus What is his name Solomon Grundy large
mass of clay and dirt enjoys poetry and basketball
difficulty with squeezing through Oh shit.
There she is, but you plan forever Wait, how is she a
villain and a pop star a song just like a pop star because
she's she's actually Super talent.
Oh my god, wait.
Assault, drug possession, DUI, tax evasion.
I guess for...
How... You can't be a supervillain if your fucking
supervillain thing is tax evasion.
Music Snap, Highlight Consistently requests a return to her
trailer.
Holographic...
How is she the supervillain?
If all she does was just evade taxes.
Like, everyone does it.
Not me.
Not...
True.
you not me though not um papa smirked you're all reformed
just like you then you put a super chat thank you so uh the
z team my team they're okay drugs are bad we're not looking
for miracles but we'd love one if we could get it can you
show him his desk sure it's not so super if you're if The
only crime is, like, drugs and tax evasion.
How is that the super part?
It's just a regular, the 1%.
Pretty sparse, but feel free to decorate.
They're just being the 1%.
That's not really quite super villain of them.
This computer's older than you look.
Wait, so we're doing this?
I haven't even met the team yet.
Only one of them, yeah, only one of them fucking committed.
committed murder what the fuck we like to start slow that's
weak as hell don't make it past the first dispatch and this
is better for everybody's safety what do you mean safety
you'll be fine and this here is our little slice of the
southland whenever there's a crisis in the area we get a
call and guess who i have to dispatch my team are the
fucking now put your headset on and introduce yourself to
these pricks what they gave me the worst people to manage
hey team this is
Tell me that's not your real first day bitch You can't be
this sugar You're happy Can we clear the channel please
There's a lot of overlapping on this Bro I got the suicide
squad I got the worst fucking Villains for this shit He's
packing much But he's got a lot of bruises Which I'm into
Again please clear the channel Clear comes Clear comes
People are dying!
Clear comms!
These calls are fucking recorded for training fucking
purposes.
So keep the fucking line clear before we send your stupid
fucking asses back to whatever fucking cell we pulled your
stupid fucking asses out of.
Damn.
Jeez.
My son's balloon is stuck in a tree.
Can you send someone?
Alright, climb a 40 feet tree to retrieve a...
Don't make the child cry.
Okay.
Someone with charisma, right?
Oh, yes, sir.
Charisma, mobility.
Okay, you can climb.
No, okay, I would assume climbing is what I'm looking for.
I have, no, she's, she'll make someone cry.
Uh-huh.
Oh, my God.
No, he's gonna make, bro, when the child sees this, it's
gonna cry.
He doesn't need to do anything.
What's your problem?
Are you sure?
I feel like, I feel like he's just gonna cry.
Okay, what have we said?
who can have hot god they all have shitty mobility okay okay
he can fly guys i don't think he can fly okay we're gonna
you know all right we'll try we'll try i think he's gonna
yeah i know i will not try okay i feel like big mistake huge
all right maybe flamb because he has fly and a little bit
of charisma he has more charisma than invisible bitch and
it's not the me mr is requesting a hero for a very important
event who's this van der stink guy willem van der stink
certified genius literally he has a certificate it's okay
genius if you need a piece of paper that says you're a
genius very high profile send someone that'll make oh okay
who would oh she'll make it she'll make us look good she's a
celebrity no she's a celebrity guys no wait why would i send
charlie sonar okay we'll send sonar right yes are you sure i
feel like prism will have the he is smart okay oh wait
you're right he is okay did i mention i went to i hope he
doesn't burn the tree down uh i'll take wednesday tuesday
guys do you think i'm i'm concerned we're taking bets on
when you'll quit guys i'm concerned okay we're gonna see if
burns the tree today's friday okay oh my god it was oh my
god we did it he didn't burn the tree down holy okay 100 i
told you guys you're on fire today after if i make games
plus one this effect guys look at that he didn't burn the
tree down we're fine i'm so good at this what's this
what oh okay i guess i fixed i hacked now Okay, I was Okay,
alright I guess I also help Utilities too Let's see if I can
do this Got you Alright Why the fuck am I doing this
Okay, but what Why am I fixing this?
I'm also A plumber?
Like, did they Buy this off of Off of S&D tech?
I can hack up a day apparently so I guess subscribers also
get free free mechanics too
alright what's this two heroes are fighting each other break
up the bra diplomatically is possible maybe prison you did
though prison duplicates the hero to the left placing their
Oh!
Because it didn't happen, Bobbob.
Wait, that's cool.
So we're going to shut up about it.
Yeah?
She can blot in them.
We needed another backup dancer.
So...
All right.
I feel like that's diplomatically.
All right, let's go.
As fast as these legs will let me.
What's this?
We're going to sign?
Oh, okay.
So it just reads their information.
All right.
Progress at the yacht club.
Pursue to return the boat in one piece.
Okay.
I think you can do it.
You're fine.
You're fast as fuck.
Let me show you.
100%.
Let's go.
Look at that.
Easy.
I told you guys.
See?
Good job, Sonar.
What's going on with Sonar?
Oh.
Sonar transforms his intelligence swaps with combat and his
charisma swaps with vigor until the next time.
We are working on controlling it.
Oh, that's fine.
I mean...
So what was your read on this Mecha Man guy?
people like it drinking alone a robot guy these idiots are
fighting over the name fight man let's try giving maybe you
that flamb you got your ass kicked by gives them the idle
makeover shut the fuck up okay fight man okay so one of them
wants to be fight man and then okay let's give you an idle
makeover maybe maybe that's what they need give them a
makeover yeah all right from this born as Sabre and the
Bruiser.
Oh, nice.
See, look at that.
I mean, that's hardcore.
That sounds hardcore as fuck.
Flamb, you're off route.
Wait, where are you going?
Flamb?
Where the fuck are you going?
Hey, someone's robbing the museum.
I don't know what you do, man.
I just started today.
Avoid motion sensors and apprehend.
Oh, God, I don't have... Oh, wait, there you go.
Sure thing.
taking over avoid yeah that's fine um maybe i'll send you
know what fuck it you guys work together you guys got this
you guys don't need charisma we just need to be invisible do
we need two i'll send two just in case here is amateur hour
oh fire at a local park has gotten out of control did you
start that fire oh the fire that's burning two blocks from
where you're standing you didn't start I don't know what
you're talking about.
I'm on break.
Okay, let's fire can be fixed later.
Okay, stop fucking around.
I've got enough problems without you making new ones.
Oh, it's 63.
Whatever, man.
Is that it?
No!
How?
Oh, it's okay.
There's no one alive on the boat anyway.
It's fine.
Jenny, the Bone Zone Diaz here.
Today's topic is all about SDN hiring criminals to protect
us.
Wrong.
Oh, shit.
Shit.
Okay, we'll wait for it.
We'll wait for him to come back.
Um, maybe.
He can throw clay at it.
Oh, shit.
Hack.
We're gonna hack the system.
I got you guys.
I got my PC, my wooden keyboard.
I can hack this.
As long as I'm not timed.
I'm timed.
I had one criteria.
Okay.
I'm timed.
Who would have thought?
Okay.
We're so done.
Oh.
Oh, if I messed up one, I didn't even realize that.
There you go, we did it.
No pressure.
No pressure at all.
We found it.
You never have too many soft skills.
Hey, a hero ranked up.
Oh, did he?
What did he do?
Upgrade?
Every rank up earns skill points.
Use them for increasing stats.
What do we want, anyway?
Uh, let's have more...
You could be more smart, actually.
What do we want?
Do we want charisma?
Or mobility?
Intelligent?
All right, let's do intelligent.
smarter only only mad bat only sonar levels up everybody
should step back we've encountered these thieves before
track known track down no members to find their hat hideout
i feel like intelligent i can wait a little bit i just need
okay here we go okay here we go it's time to educate them he
said i got arrested for tax evasion i wish Okay, what do...
Okay, we've counted these thieves before.
Compile and cross-reference pass case, okay?
Going now!
Track down members to find their hide up.
Maybe?
Yeah, okay.
Well, we have to track them down, wouldn't you... Maybe
these two?
Ag and...
Tata.
Ag and Mobility.
I feel like you need intelligence, but none of them are
smart in my crew.
This is a little bit.
This is bad.
I don't have any smart people in my crew.
Alright, we can wait a little bit.
Disrupted?
Use your body.
Just use your body.
You're made of clay.
You're fine.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, that's good.
We contained it.
Alright.
Okay, there we go.
Mobility?
And we need someone smart.
which is none of them that's fine we'll send these to damn
dude how'd you get an ass like that hello squads girl oh i
was afraid you'd say we're doing so good guys look at that
we can reform the villains all right do you educate them i
swear to god okay 89 that's good don't be intimidated job
charlie business half man half bat all freak all right this
should be fine this was not fine oh yeah it was fine oh
thank god okay it is fine okay keep forgetting yellow is us
or what yellow is is us hey bobby here william vanders think
needs a security detail uh i'm willing to pitch him some
stuff i've been working on mobility too pretty sure that's
exactly what he's trying to avoid and then charisma let's go
you can only choose one solution okay send sonar send
literally anyone else sure send sonar high-ranking van der
stanker it would mean a lot let sonar meet his hero william
and pitch him ideas once you the other option will disappear
all right oh i can wait it's okay give me a sec Oh, shit.
Okay, what's this?
That little shit I wanted behind you.
Track down and encourage him to turn his life around.
Gosh, okay.
We'll think about it.
All right.
It's okay.
He's resting.
All right, there you go.
I don't know if you should meet his hero while he's a...
You know what?
Fuck it.
Never meet your heroes.
Sure.
Go ahead.
You will not regret this.
Never meet your heroes.
I didn't think I would until you said that.
Alright.
He's gotta learn.
Guys.
He's gotta learn to never meet his heroes.
He'll...
JLV.
Go for it.
Guys, he's a Harvard graduate.
He's gonna learn today.
Self and use and will be key.
Okay.
It's well guarded.
Oh.
We'll send these two.
We'll send them both together.
How long was the last dispatcher here?
Two days.
Yeah, no shit.
How the fuck did that happen?
Oh, the nerves.
And he's second guessing his human meat alternative.
How's make it relate?
Just wait.
Oh, God.
Oh, fuck.
I don't know.
I don't know if he is relatable, guys.
He's a Harvard graduate.
It's really hard to make it relatable.
Should you wing it or make it relatable?
it he's not he's not really oh just tell a story oh god uh
oh man this feels like a fail wing it we fall i feel like
winging it would be like charisma and we don't really have
any of that right now story is bad guys which one is it okay
because he wing it because he's a bat
wing it okay i don't know sonar just uh you know just wing
it well that seems i feel like that's correct oh oh you know
wing it fly maybe stretch but you know come on don't turn
into a monster oh i realized that now yeah oh i told you
guys freak some out never meet your heroes guys i told you
never meet your heroes
protect capture the thieves maybe get the paintings out oh
get the paintings out quietly we have her paintings out
quietly yeah there you go i was gonna say i have her got
some option they caught oh scare the kids straight that's
right the kids straight that should tell her she's gonna go
to hell if he keeps going scaring children obviously my
favorite part of the job Or is it scared straight?
Tell the kid he'll go to hell.
Alright, nice.
What the fuck?
Granies, I got this.
Hold up.
Aren't you banned?
Yeah, and I gotta get unbanned.
Wait, do we put her in?
Yeah, nice try, dude.
I'm not going anywhere.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I have to put her in.
Okay.
You know, I'm not going for you.
I'm going because I have to.
Ascent reduces travel time and call completion time.
He just really likes grannies, I guess.
Anything I could level up?
No, okay.
Can I get ice down here, please?
What does that mean?
What?
She asked before tapping.
We got access to security cams of SDN subscribers all over
our territory.
Wow.
Really?
Is that legal?
Don't ask questions.
Just always make sure to read the fine print.
Didn't know you were a fellow monster.
But she's thinking about a super chat thingy thingy.
yeah oh shit what's going on hello right i feel like you've
said that a lot in your life what happened yeah what
happened this is how i found the place the old guy who i
assume is granny was laying here that's granny look can you
just focus what you got adhd or something yes is it that
obvious yes it is well then answer the question i want to
sit here and fixate on it when we're supposed to be doing
whatever superhero see the long cream ones uh long ones with
the cream inside it clears um oh they're called oh oh it's
french yep you got me i love gobbling on hot sloppy guys
guys not guys guys no i just i like eclipse guys guys first
day they're french
Guys!
Maybe I'll dress.
Body room.
What are you doing?
You're gonna poke it with a stick?
Check his pulse.
Granny's alive.
Thank Christ.
I didn't want to have to lift this guy.
So, can I go now?
No, this isn't a wellness check.
It's a B&E.
Let's figure out if the PURP is still there.
PURP?
B&E?
Okay, Lieutenant.
Fuck, I can't think of a character from a cop show.
Cool.
Well, why don't you stay put and work on that while I get
another camera up online.
she's my least favorite the worst of the lot that surprises
me you guys got similar energy how do i switch cameras don't
know if you're interested thank you we're getting tech
advice from an old person bro i'm not even oh he's 39
hearing bro from an old person dan lieutenant dan is that is
that a thing yes i am the legless vietnam vet from forest
gump sick burn access to nine what uh am i doing pushing
that button just says access denied ah damn it sometimes
people add extra security they don't understand it just
makes it harder for us to do our job oh god am i hacking or
something or you just it's a donut shop what kind of
security do you need in a donut shop clearly not a really
good donut shop if there's no one there bro there's no one
even in this donut shop oh my god it's money laundering
isn't it
here isn't he why does a donut shop even need extra exactly
that's what i'm saying there's nobody even eating here what
what the what do i do this that's odd oh
the key oh Oh!
I thought it was one of those, like, guest things where,
like, if you get a thing right, uh...
This code represents a code to use later.
Remember it.
Okay.
Up, down, left, left.
I thought it was one of those, like... It's, like, Wordle.
I thought it was Wordle.
God, the dude thought it was Wordle.
It would have been smart if it was Wordle.
What we got here?
Perp, V&E.
Who are you, Lieutenant Dan?
Sack, you're not alone.
What's this?
He's coming your way, armed.
You need to disappear.
Why are you whispering, you idiot?
You're in my ear.
No, now!
Is this shroud?
Oh, shit.
It's defense this now.
Oh, wait, he asked his other thing.
It's just a gusher.
Be careful.
I got this lieutenant Dan.
Never mind.
Oh He has like a name by eye cheating Got any more great
advice?
Oh shit.
No, it's her deep up asthma.
Oh Stupid I was watching to cut teeth
Shit I want a donut too.
Oh shit!
Invisible bitch!
Invisible!
Just hold him off while you find a way to help.
Oh, am I hacking?
I can use the overhead sprinklers to short out his blaster.
Oh shit, oh I'm timed.
Okay, I was gonna say as long as I'm not timed, it'll be
fine.
Why?
Got him.
What?
Okay.
Up down.
Oh?
Oh shit.
Up down.
Okay, what's this?
Up, down, left, up, up, down, left, up, down, left, up,
down, left, up, down, left, up, up, down, left, up, up,
down, left, up, up, down.
Wait, why am I doing that?
I should be using you guys.
Oh my.
Nice.
Water badge.
I should have been using at chat.
Oh, fuck.
No, my asthma.
Who's that?
Who came in?
Phenomenal.
Oh, granny!
I don't think you know how to use that thing, so why don't
you...
Shut the fuck up!
Oh, I'm one of the good guys.
You?
Yeah, right.
Don't fuck with me, okay?
Nobody fucks, granny.
Oh, shit.
Shit!
Great fucking advice, Lieutenant Dan.
You're not calling me, Lieutenant Dan.
Take out the thief.
The show doesn't work and you shout dumb.
Granny doesn't even know how to shoot that thing.
Yeah, I don't trust him.
He's the only one with this finger on a trigger.
You know what?
It's my life on the line.
I'm done listening to you.
The thing's gonna blow that man's arm off and there's a
whole building with me in it.
Fuck off, I'm disarming the device.
No, Invisig out, that's a direct order.
Wait, she doesn't even care?
What?
I- He didn't even listen to me!
Bro!
Oh, fuck.
Fuck.
Invisiga, you there?
Oh, shit, that's his dick.
Oh, his ass?
Fuck, this guy's heavy.
Granny's clearly a fan of- She's gone rogue!
Oh, he's kind of caked up.
I think he must have had something else to do, because he
left.
I mean...
Oh, wait, does he have life insurance?
Oh, he's alive?
You think he'll still be subscribed?
Guys, do you think he'll cancel his subscription, guys?
Sometimes people, you know, get electrical burns.
She disobeyed a direct order.
Well, that's the problem.
This isn't the army and these ain't soldiers.
Guys, he's not going to unsubscribe, right?
Maybe if we send him one free month.
One free month, he'll stay on.
It's okay, guys.
We'll give him a voucher.
And if you're sorry, you got shot.
sure you're not actually 80 years old.
Sorry, you guys tried.
Here's one month free.
Alright.
Two failures?
It wasn't even my fault.
Bro, one of the failures wasn't even my fault.
You could hear out of resting.
About random point.
Oh, nice.
here's one here to receive the combat skill upgrade oh um do
i want to be stronger all right you guys you guys at chat
well i'll let you guys pick you know what i'll let you guys
pick punch up
punch up all right i'll give punch up his little combat yeah
i'll let you guys customize my team we do it together we're
a team
Oh, hey, Twinkie.
Oh, yeah, they're back.
Oh, gross.
Whoa, shit.
What kind of superhero flinches?
I'm just a dispatcher.
I didn't think we were a superhero.
Chill out.
If you had people trying to kill you for the last 15 years,
you'd be jumpy, too.
What makes you think my life has been any different?
You think growing up surrounded by a bunch of shipbag
villains?
I didn't need to watch my back.
I can't just disappear.
yeah i actually have to face my problems what the fuck you
can't just go around ow why is he keep screaming his name
sonar yeah i know it's sonar is he blind what's up what's up
you know what never mind good shift this guy is weird yeah
he is look i actually just came by to celebrate the mission
going well didn't mean to interrupt your little snack what
do you need to preach you like a little baby bird bitch you
ignored my order direct order how can you exactly soldier
trash the place the suspect got away you got the client hurt
you think when that guy signed up for sd and the head result
in the back of his ball sack getting scorched because they
don't mention that in the commercials first of all the place
was trashed when i got there second i'm sure granny would
take some crispy nuts over losing his arm as far as the bad
guy fuck shit happens the fact of the matter is that shit
didn't need to happen yeah because what the fuck was he
saying doesn't get fried and we get me you ask for help then
i can what what's he doing what the is he grinding coffee i
make the calls not you here's some advice you're right at
home behind that desk because you're no hero you were a nerd
playing a video game and a suit your daddy built now you're
a twitchy little bitch turtle without its shell but she
knows who i am too a real hero can't just press a button
make their problem you don't need me the fact of the matter
is you need me way more that's right bitch based on what i
saw today you wouldn't last a day as mecha man because there
isn't a mech suit in the universe that will keep you from
being a selfish oh yeah she was in that room i already
forgot about her she's so invisible oh yes do you think i'm
in i think she likes that when i talk back to her whoa good
fuck you guys you think i'm in
You're gonna eat those twinks?
That's not what they're...
You know what?
And I can't romance him!
What the fuck?
What happened to your nose?
Hmm?
There we go.
You have a tissue hanging from your nose, Robert.
I was trying to ignore it, but...
Yeah, so I'm gonna snitch.
I'm snitching.
Invisi got punched me in the face.
But I asked for it.
this is serious bro this game is so good i'm clearly got
here playing it thank you thank you i said i literally yeah
this is pretty enjoyable i've been enjoying the story so far
i he eats swings and i can't romance him exactly let's go
with that i'm a nerd roberts for a shift and aside from
whatever happened here i thought it was she punched me i'm
reporting to hr watching on the monitor the work you did
dispatching i don't think the z team has ever had a better
shift than that we just might need to confront the fact that
it might be the best they can do especially the way the
granny thing went yeah the z situation that wasn't ideal but
i've seen so much worse with invisigal let's be real she
ain't gonna make it she's difficult to work with sure but i
see a lot of promise in her really even the other z-teamers
respect her they're afraid of her i should have done better
maybe a couple wires got crossed toward the end there guys
what do you mean the romance option is god i'm gonna save it
okay i'll save it cost them for you i'm gonna save it you
should be proud the bar is very low with this group well
it's not low for me look i like to make a joke and keep
things light as much as the next person but when it comes to
where i could turn it around here if you want the phoenix
program to survive the bar needs to go up and how would we
do that by treating the z team like what they are a bunch of
villains villain team takes a different approach than a
superhero team.
I need to be around them.
I need them to see I'm all in and they need to match that
energy.
Some tough love.
The only kind I know and based on what I've seen the only
version they'll respond to.
I'm not saying everyone will make it.
They won't.
I'm not saying it won't get spicy.
It will.
But when it does, I also need you to trust me to handle it.
I don't want you stepping in.
They need to respect me even if I
okay we'll do it your way monday we'll get them in a room
and introduce them to their new super villain leader as me i
can't promise at work i can only promise that i'll do my
best what if i like poached them and start my own company
way more fun to watch but then it's for like super villains
only so it's like people have to subscribe to us to make
sure we don't kill them i feel like that's more money hey
kid what what are you doing yeah no no no no i did it did
this it's so it's weird because yeah i saw this lady so it's
a mob desk earlier previously and it was nice nicely on a
napkin yeah and they don't want to unsubscribe the moment
they unsubscribe they're dead so people who aren't
subscribed they get killed and we reduce we get more
customers because people don't want to die see i'm sdn's
newest fucking over a water boy okay cool so it's my pleases
pleasure and it's a business model it's not a crime we get
so thank you thank you so much happy to help that's it's
Friday I'm not gonna ask you headed out oh yeah um great
thanks kid welcome to the team water boy yeah welcome to you
You too.
What even is his powers?
Like, was he just...
Oh, God!
Oh, oh, fuck!
Guys, I know what his powers are.
I want you to know what his powers are.
I want you to have a contingent on you as a busy team.
I want to do that to you.
But don't worry about that.
I'm just...
I mean, shouldn't have ass.
I shouldn't.
No, do you want to grab dinner?
Hey, so do you want to grab dinner or something?
Like, as like platonic, you know?
Platonic friends, you know?
Actually, there's something I've been meaning to tell you.
It's a little awkward to mention, but since the other night,
I...
Blonde Blazer.
Hey.
Oh, it's that guy.
He saw it.
He was in the commercial that we saw.
What?
Who is this?
I thought I'd catalogued all of your work companions.
You hoi!
Oh my god, it's so proud of music.
Bro, oh my god, Bowser Jr. Robert Robertson, leader of the
Phoenixes.
Blonde Blazer told me about you.
Really?
Did she say, I don't know, what came up in that talk?
She said you're a capable, honorable man that truly cares
for others.
Why are you so small?
Hey, come on.
You gotta stop asking people.
Oh, it's above average.
It's not about the size.
It's the flow.
It's all about how you use this.
Lack of size and strength and issue.
No, he was great.
It was great.
It was a great first day That is phenomenal.
We should celebrate blonde blazer and I have reservations in
Tokyo at a restaurant where the owner Dreams of sushi you
should join us You know what I think I will you know what I
will that's right that's I will blonde blazer That's fucking
right I don't know if we can add one more to the that's a
Ricky Rand, I'm gonna sit in that chair.
Us to get there in time, we'd have to hit supersonic speed
and Robert here.
Oh, would he die?
Yeah, I think he would die.
Oh, no.
Perhaps another time.
Yeah, for sure.
That's fucking right.
What do you mean, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Why did you not tell me you were dating him?
He flies a little faster.
Manly, you could have told me this like two days ago.
A pleasure.
Now, could you step back?
The power of my life.
She has no right to say what the fuck?
Phenomenal.
Oh, shit.
Yeah, he flies a lot faster.
There's no such thing as it's complicated.
Just be like, I'm dating someone.
What the fuck do you mean?
She said it's complicated.
You know what she could have said?
Sorry.
I didn't mean to fucking flirt with you.
I have a boyfriend.
all you have to say.
Yeah, uncomplicated.
You know, instead of saying what you can say other than it's
complicated, I have a boyfriend.
You could have just said that.
Oh, yeah, I was going to say, bro, who are the people that
didn't, bro, because that's fucked.
That phenomenal small being patuistic, a super chat thank
you thank you oh i ratted me a 24 ratted her out you and you
and 26 attempted to ask blazer out you and 10 said yes to
the donor
yes sir no god all i'm saying is that it's i have to okay i
I had to, I had to, like, rub it in.
You and Twit left Sonar meet, and it went terrible.
Never beat your heroes!
I didn't do the saver and the bruiser.
That, that, the name is fucking fire, though.
That is a fire name.
Your most sent hero is Sonar.
You perform better.
See, I perform better in 50% of theirs i got 50 50.
uh love the malta as long as i'm not timed i'll be fine
dokey's saying this game in full of quick time events and
time risk never change dokey it's bye look
all i'm saying i just never meet your heroes i was teaching
sonar a lesson i want to grab some food wait let me
microwave some food real quick all right i'll be right back
guys i want to microwave some food real quick
Also grab some water.
I know!
I am back!
I got food.
Sorry, it took me a while.
I had to reheat my food.
Alright, there we go.
I'm ready.
Thank God I can watch stuff too.
Smokey Mike Pado, Matt.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I had, like, a teriyaki beef and shrimp rice.
That didn't finish.
So I can...
Yesterday.
So I'm gonna finish it today.
Mmm, shit.
it whoa whoa whoa hey what are you doing brother your
warranty already boy i don't know about finishing this game
today we'll see by chat we'll see on chapter four worries
i'm pretty strong that's not what i'm saying how you got
this thing inside your apartment anyways oh super heavy the
bugger i disassembled it and took it in little pieces which
is what i thought you'd be doing and how long that took you
three or no it was four days i get 20 minutes That's true.
It just feels like you could be a little gentler with it.
It is, you know, my whole fucking life.
Every time I walk in this place, I get sad.
That don't happen to you.
No one ever told you.
Bro, I'm poor.
Why do you think I take this job?
Does that make you feel good?
I don't have subscribers.
You're not poor if you can keep this suit going.
Like, where are you sleep?
In this chair?
Figuring that out.
You're figuring that out, huh?
So even the beef got a bed.
This is the type of apartment you see when the detective
kicked the door in.
You know, shine the flashlight, serial killer shit.
All right, I get it.
Can we focus on...
Where the Astral Pole's at?
Lost in the blast while I was flying.
No clue where it landed.
Bro, this is like...
I spent a couple weeks after it happened trying to track it
down.
Single male living space.
And that's me.
The only piece of the suit my dad didn't have schematics
for.
Is that gonna be a problem?
Ah, mine now.
We figure them out.
That's literally how I live, too.
How'd you know about that?
Oh, but everybody know about the pulse.
It's actually two wicked pieces of tech, huh?
Well, first you get the Astral Pulse, this genius design
energy cell.
But inside them, you get the stellar core.
Can I help?
No, brother.
You good.
What's crazy is when you mix the control fusion reactions
with the plasma containment.
Oh, brother.
You got a core one, super crazy, energized plasma state.
Unreal stuff.
Like you caught one small star and chop them in a bottle.
Genius.
Oh, good.
You said we're good.
Ashtapaw's super awesome, but we'll be all right.
Whew.
Man, maybe we go for a lot of medals this time, huh?
You know, I actually met your dad one time, long time ago.
First time I come mainland, he'll catch me trying for steal
stuff from Radio Shack.
Then we talk tech stuff for like an whole hour.
Then he would take me to jail.
That's how I ended up in the Phoenix program.
Wait, he was a villain?
had with him oh almost yes when you're building astropulses
there's not much time for talking oh yeah he has big daddy
issues not so sure about that i don't understand you see
there's gear heads then there's science nerds one kind
garage the other kind lab you know your father won't go gear
head but i just can't see how he'll make something like the
pulse he knows science nerd how would you know this from
talking to him maybe he used to work with shroud because i'm
both True, I'm the one going to fix your suit.
Oh my god, what if Shroud was the one that made him the
thing?
That one over there.
That's your father's suit.
We're going to make this one the robber's suit.
The robber's suit.
This is incredible, Royd.
I hope you like the brother.
Royd.
I don't know what to say.
Thank you.
Thank you is what I need to say.
This is unreal.
We make the man Mika again.
Oh my god.
I'm going to have a job again.
Or like, I guess technically it wasn't my job.
I was doing it for free.
My phone.
Watch where you're going, bro.
Hey.
Yeah.
Watch where you're going.
I think you did that on purpose.
That's right.
I fend for myself.
I'm not gonna let him walk over me just because he's made a
play.
I'm his manager.
Look at Rude, he bumps into me!
Hey, Chase, I need a favor.
How am I the rude man?
Not enough of a favor getting you this job, working with
those stupid ass pieces of- Oh, who's this, huh?
Who's this little guy?
His name's Beef, and he's the favor.
you mind keeping an eye out I feel bad leaving him at home
but I don't want anything happening to him Robert I would
literally let everyone here melt in eternal hell including
you before anything happens to this I'm sorry no what's your
name little guy my name's beef and I'm naked oh no I refuse
to believe that's what he sounds like Robert you got a sec
sure yeah I'm gonna tell him yeah i'm gonna tell him he's
like don't tell him don't tell him i cheated about the other
day with phenomena man oh yeah how's dinner oh it was
awkward it's why i didn't want you to come phenomenal man
and i oh wait she broke up with him sushi yeah it's just oh
my god i have a chance now timing felt right i don't know
sometimes you just gotta shake shut up it felt a little are
you happy I'm coming it's hard to say what did I contribute
did I do it oh why would you have contributed to it guess
that means I didn't which is what I was hoping for it is
what it is over sushi actually not what I wanted to talk to
you about I was thinking about it over the weekend and I'm
going to cut someone from the Z team you want to be rebound
a fucking course I do that's Dear?
Bro, she's a muscle mommy.
Urgency.
Oh.
You sure about that?
Well, less sure now.
You think it's a bad idea?
I'm just not sure how it'll play out.
The reality is cutting someone towards the bottom of the
leaderboards will show everyone we're serious.
They're not at the bottom.
I'll let the team know.
Oh, I already did.
What?
I suppose it'll be an interesting shift.
Oh, they're all going to complete.
competed show of each other oh yeah she ain't bad oh did you
come over here to tell me that because it's wait sonar
second last I came over to tell you that oh she's second
last bro he was killing it sonar you all right why are you
sending a distress call when you haven't left the building
could you send a What happened?
What happened?
Coup seduced me.
No.
I said, hey, I want to say something cool.
And then...
So I assumed you meant boobs.
Someone's getting cut, but don't let that distract you from
doing a good job out there.
You graduated from Harvard, guys.
What a bunch of bullshit.
Sorry.
What's bullshit?
It could happen to anyone.
How is that?
Yeah, only God can judge me.
Okay.
Only God can...
No one can judge me, but God.
false of course i'm being judged along with the rest of you
are you do not know what a job is what the hell is going on
wait wait it's all right fine just ignore the pressure and
do your jobs you don't need to be first you just can't be
last uh what about me can somebody go down to the gym and
help bat boner who the guy who's shaped like a bat uh losing
feeling in my hand and then It was gonna help him.
Kinky way.
There was an altercation with my team and a monster down at
the beach.
And there's some debris of...
Little giant monster.
Large media and civvy.
Okay, so we need someone to be able to move.
Okay, we need someone with charisma.
And, alright.
There we go.
I think we can pull this off.
Wait, what?
I didn't put you in there.
What?
okay you look uh different you mean better on a call with
certain slots may grant plus two and eyes others when golem
is assigned okay what what oh they're competing now oh shit
okay
okay yeah we can do this that's fine what go and put
laxatives are you serious fight the force it out of your
okay bro you're working to you're not even last uh mind over
focus on the job I don't know force it out of your system
bro just fucking poop it out yeah no poop it out there's no
way force it out man I I don't think you can hold it in.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, there we go.
Just poop that up.
I did unspeakable things in that alley.
Uh-huh.
You know, this is really fucking immature guys.
Serves them right.
You let your guard down.
You perish.
What is this?
What is F?
That's a pretty fucked way to live.
Emphasis on live.
Oh, my God.
You do realize that sabotaging each other isn't going to
guarantee you a spot on the team, right?
Oh, no.
No.
Oh, and he gets...
Okay, there's stats.
If it gets hurt, they'll become...
Okay, that's not good.
Okay, this is...
Oh, gosh.
There's a drug deal happening at the Torn's airport right
now.
I think you should send the bat guy.
Convincingly...
Pose as a buyer.
Preferably someone highly educated on drugs.
Oh, that's Prism.
That's Prism, isn't it?
Yeah, that's...
Sona knows jobs.
I'm going!
Let's send the Prism and send the...
Oh, it's done.
Oh, man.
Why?
Bye-bye.
I feel like...
We'll send both of them.
You know what?
I'll send both of them in.
Sona and Sona who is recovering.
Yeah.
Here we go.
Maybe Prism can help him out.
Drug bust.
Fuck yeah.
My two favorite things.
Drugs and booze.
Soner Docs who is now being...
Oh, what?
What?
Surprise drops are good for a brand.
Distract them with a sign.
There we go.
You got this.
Playing the hits?
Works every time.
We have to go back?
Oh yeah.
Soner is getting...
Goodbye.
sonar bro sonar ain't cool so turtle fans moved in flipped a
grill started a fight and and ruined a bunch of hot dogs go
on offensive if you have to all right i'll dispatch one guy
rise up the ranks around here would everybody please stay in
your lanes all right oh wait it wasn't sabotage oh We did it
Be right back.
Just got to go powder my cocaine Nice Dude, you promised me
you were gonna come back.
I will right after this bomb We follow the drug traffickers
to base go on strike to bring lots of sad We prepared for a
lot of firepower.
I thought it was like bait shit, you know, okay?
I thought it was bait.
Okay combat.
Oh, whatever you say okay there you go bring lots of
firepower that's a lot oh but then they're like gonna
sabotage each other though why don't i just bring him okay
surely if i send three people they won't sabotage each other
i feel like all three are just gonna sabotage each other
though i'm pretty sure i don't think i don't yeah yeah i
don't know i feel like all three are just gonna sabotage to
their base near the refinery.
Let's shut them down for good.
Bring three and then maybe they'll be okay?
Alright, let's bring three.
Let's bring three.
Maybe they won't sabotage all three.
It's playing a loud sound to death and sonar.
If I wasn't in ever increasing pain.
He's a grown man, bad hybrid.
Dug up your ears.
Oh my god, track down the source.
I mean, we know it's coop.
We know it's cool Can do you think he can I feel like I mean
what is he gonna do after he tracks her down?
Plug your ears.
You'll be fine.
You got big.
Yeah You can plug it up You cannot plug it up you cannot oh
my god.
Okay.
Okay guys.
Oh my god.
Okay I can't move.
Oh You know what I wanted to know if he could become one
with it prideful can incorporate into your body you're now
You're now clay cement golem It's fine you can't get double
hurt He can in fact get double hurt
He can indeed okay
Oh God just made it in thank God That was too close.
That was so close.
Okay.
Hey, my grandma just got scammed by someone claiming they
work for you guys.
Better intel on the scam and scammer.
Okay.
Social security numbers.
All the bad numbers.
Speak to that victim.
You know what?
I can send...
I don't know who's best friends with each other.
I don't know.
I actually don't know.
Let's see.
We'll put...
charisma.
And, you know what?
Charisma.
There you go.
Alright, oh, they work together.
Okay, that's good.
Okay, that's not good.
We know that's good.
They work together.
Oh, God, this is scary.
Well, we made it.
Alright, that's good.
That's good, guys.
We're all proud of you.
We're all so proud of you.
Alright, uh...
Intel gathering I feel like you gotta be smart for that
right?
Oh, but I don't have a smart person.
I mean maybe?
You two work well together.
You got someone that can figure out how to stop a landslide?
Stand aside.
As hot and threatening as that sounds.
I'm not going anywhere.
We're tied for the bottom.
With fucking Invisigal.
Not for long.
Alright.
So, reinforced.
Oh, okay.
You guys... Wait, but you guys hate each other.
Wait, but you guys hate each other.
I mean...
Oh, my gosh.
Okay, that's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
You guys hate each... It's okay.
It's so... It's okay.
I'm fine with that.
It's okay.
Surely.
It'll be okay.
Oh, my God.
Okay, so did I push me into They refused to let me leave.
I hate the water and old people.
You have signed your death warrant.
Worth it.
Next time.
Don't promise a man boobs.
No one promised you anything.
Describe your diarrhea earlier?
So when I pushed me in the pool, during the water, they
refused to let me leave.
I hate the water and old people.
Do I just backstroke away?
Or do I describe backstroke away?
Maybe I can swim away.
where is that oh thank god okay i know i have a lot of
mobility i just swam away you should really see my butterfly
stroke all right has turned into the mascot inquisition
catch up with the roundies hands forever this suit is too
hot okay oh shit all my fast people are god oh wait no here
catch up and i remember he was chill he was chill with man
going already he was chill with her yeah they were they're
chill like that yeah what happened she's fine just walked
into my sword with her face a little bit i don't believe in
punching women but i do believe in punching demons yeah i
mean understandable understand she is they look like oh come
on charlie oh wait we made it oh thank god Thank fucking
God.
Wait, but you guys were chill!
Statistically speaking.
Nobody sabotages me except me!
You guys were chill!
I'll unlock the tape, bro.
What the fuck?
I sent you two together!
Why were you- why did you guys not be chill?
Until I closed the lid.
They were chill like that, I remembered.
They like hanged out in everything.
There we go.
Like, what happened?
Yeah, yeah, what the fuck did you do?
Don't worry, I'm coming over.
God, chill.
Still got it.
Like, I remember.
I remember he was fine.
What the fuck happened?
Alright.
Left, down, down.
Okay.
Yeah, just take your fucking time.
Don't worry, you're okay.
Left, down, down.
There you go.
Palisade, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I spoke too soon.
It's not the kind of wet I like to be, Robert.
I still, I don't know what...
I don't know their chemistry.
I still don't know.
Oh.
Let's put it here.
I just boost their best stuff.
that.
Lambay is friends with... Okay, Prism.
Okay.
Can we get some help over here?
The lot is packed.
No one moved in like an hour.
Oh, that's for Prism.
Okay.
A bandco cyber train with precious cargo aboard is minutes
away from colliding with the stopped freight and the
station.
The precious...
Okay.
Um...
Hold the train before it crashes.
I assume defense, right?
Yeah, defense.
and charisma.
All right, who is Punch-Up friends with?
Invisigal and Golem?
Yeah, but they're...
Golem is out.
Golem ain't coming in.
Is Punch-Up and Koop...
Oh, Punch-Up and Koop are friends?
All right, that's good.
You're not gonna like what you see anyway.
All right, this one I need Prism.
Prism.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
I'm like, whoa, I'm luck is on my side today.
So uh, holy fuck Hey, so like my friend's boyfriend was like
bragging about how he pretends to be SDN and scams people
He's a real piece of shit deliver the says looking for it
not a fight.
Okay, first up We're gonna put We're gonna put Prism in
here, okay And then, you know what?
Bro, is Prism and Sonar cool?
I don't know.
Hmm.
Prism and Flamb...
Oh, it's gone?
No, it's not.
It's right here.
Oh, shit!
Sonar.
Invis.
Wait, are they good, friends?
Oh.
My god Guys, no, oh fuck okay fine The hell man Oh, no, oh
no, okay here come no I was about to click that.
Okay.
It's so we so fast.
It's going so fast Sure thing I forgot who they're friends
with How's my hair perfect as always?
Friends?
You smell weird.
Trying on a new cologne.
Oh, they're friends.
Stop trying this.
They're friends.
Oh, God.
Come on.
I think I'm going to use me head.
He cannot be.
Oh, yeah.
He doesn't.
Yeah, it's all right.
That's good.
You got two.
That was okay.
Sonar's not going to die.
Oh.
Oh, oh god Not only wasn't it our guy, but we let the other
creep escape Bro, you went to Harvard Soda Half man, half
bad All freak You went to Harvard How do you fuck this up,
bro?
Okay, surely she doesn't fuck this up for me Okay, thank god
no stopping me thank god i knew i could count off lambay in
prism heading towards the omni street
really oh oh she needs it out of my way fuck off what are
you doing in visigal hey what are you doing it's like you
said the way to win this leaderboard game is to not lose
right yeah that's not what i said i'm pretty sure that's
what you said
I'm thinking I'm oh my god I'm cooking too much wait that's
sabotage bitch oh shit
what the fuck is going on lightning struck so the purple
that just ran by was lightning struck this is now the second
time you let him get away no shit That's crazy.
Yeah, don't piss off the fucking demons.
Oh, shit.
I'd normally say cut her, but the way things are going, I'd
cut the whole damn team.
You need a reset, Robbie.
All Z team back to base and in the conference room in 20
minutes.
Eleven cars.
lack of teen what it didn't even matter is
it scripted oh it's scripted okay
it's not me it's not me it's not my fault it's not my fault
it's scripted thank god i knew i wasn't the issue
I just think this is a waste of time.
Yeah, I know.
What are we doing here?
What the fuck is the point of this?
I'd rather be somewhere else.
I had a thousand better things to do.
There is so many- Spire, welcome, welcome.
I'm playing them DPS.
I can't believe they count romantic.
Like, look at her.
Hey, can I get your attention, please?
I would like to get started.
Oh, shit.
Oh, look like this motherfucker got the power to fly.
That's it, call him!
Get out!
Oh, you're going out!
serves you right hey you get out of here yeah you yeah
Barney rubble fuck off you can ask you gotta know I'm in
charge here then I won't just kick you out of this room I'll
kick you out of the whole Phoenix program you can go back to
whatever life was so lame that you thought coming here was
an improvement or you can step outside and think that's
fucking right why you're here something everyone in this
room should be thinking about
That's right.
You understand, bro?
That's fucking right.
How am I rude?
He fucking slammed me in.
He's got to learn.
I'm not gonna let him push me around.
What's this shit about?
Let's go.
Come on.
I'm fucking wasting my time.
Let's go.
Okay.
As you know, by the end of today, one of you will be cut
from the z team this is bullshit yeah you said that already
call me from a job i didn't want in the first place miss
blazer maybe if you gave us a dispatcher who knew what they
were doing you wouldn't have to throw no one out hey nikki
mirage i'm standing right here you can talk to me i wasn't
talking to you which weak-ass superhero team did you come
from fucking geek squad doesn't matter where i'm from cardi
c what matters is i'm here to figure out who stays and who
Damn.
You hipster motherfucker?
Over here looking like Mumford fucked all his sons.
That's not a bad leader.
That was funny.
See?
We're just forcing balls.
Keep talking.
You won't have your tiny inbred balls left to bust.
Ask next time.
Or there won't be a next time.
Don't threaten me, you butterknife bitch.
Oh, shit.
No, they're just bad people.
Most people will look around.
They're not fixable.
That's why.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're just not fixable.
It's not my fault.
Run in the mill, vanilla fucking villains.
But that's not what I see.
Because lucky for you, I'm not most people.
When I look around this room, what I see is...
Potential.
Both are in the end.
Unfortunately for you, it's a curse.
Because there isn't a thing in the universe that goes more
wasted than potential.
And despite how common it is, no one seems to forget.
It's what they whisper when you leave the room.
Oh, so-and-so had so much potential.
It follows you forever.
I'm here to help you lift the curse of potential by getting
you to fucking do something with it.
Potential man.
You're all part of the Phoenix program.
Any of you know what a Phoenix is?
Oh, a city in Arizona.
Yeah, the sweltering ball sack of America.
Then Louisiana's got to be the ball sack.
Just, you know, position.
Phoenix.
Sorry.
Attention, man.
This is a beautiful bird of prey that was so tired of its
immortality.
It tricked the sun god into dropping a spark on its nest to
set it ablaze.
Burning it to shit.
But instead of dying, the Phoenix emerged from ash.
Look, I give them tough love and then like glaze them up.
All of you in this room are Phoenixes and it's obvious what
that means.
But for you dumb ones, I'll spell it out.
good cop i'm both redemption is what you're here for is what
connects everyone in this room to burn up who you were to
become who you were meant to be you back going can't listen
to this also a lame ass band my lame ass roommate listens to
you're late i like that band he would what are you talking
about i was here the whole time i turned invisible genius
remember great then you know we're cutting someone and you
miss hot topic sale are at the bottom of the leaderboards
have a better second shift oh
it's a second shift time oh are they gonna work together now
thanks all right everyone you heard the man get out there
and do some stellar dispatching you've got this Are they
gonna work together now, guys?
Huh?
What is this?
Take a hero out of resting.
Okay, I just filled him up with coffee.
Check the info for tags.
What tags?
Oh, Defender Versatile.
Okay.
Alright, this is fine.
Nah, he's cool.
Look, he's not cool.
My client requires protection while he does some shopping.
I remember this man.
And he's right to be paranoid.
Secret police hired me three years ago to kill him.
He pissed off the wrong dictator.
Protect the subscriber from ancient while he shops.
He can protect.
What?
Golem.
There you go, Golem.
Protect the...
I feel like I need...
Bigger, right?
I was...
See, I put him back in.
Prepare to fend off any incoming attack.
I feel like I should be prepared.
Yeah, I feel like...
Fine.
There we go.
Yeah, he should be fine.
No, he's fine.
He can't be Ingy.
Or a mudslide.
He's fine.
He's gotta force him to work.
Yeah, and he has defense.
Okay.
Some bitch just cut me in line at the Utopia concert.
I've been here for 12 fucking hours.
Utopia is a hack.
I like her.
You basic bat.
You've got super hearing and you use it to listen to a girl
who knows four chords and can't write a song to save her
life.
Say what you want.
It's catchy.
Unbelievable.
I feel like I need someone.
What, charisma?
Sonar?
I guess I could.
Yeah.
Intelligence.
Yeah, let's do it.
Guess what I found out last night?
The SDN office.
All right, did you do okay?
The Cold War CIA prison.
And torrents.
Okay, 73.
I know, isn't that sick?
The odds are in my favor.
There you go, Golem.
Look at that.
Now you, maybe you won't get cut now.
I'll put that in.
Why is there like, there's an extra somewhere.
I don't know where.
See that, right?
oh there oh she just got it okay no i'll make you a little
smarter yo mao what kind of music you got in your heavy
rotation right now you know honestly it's a lot of skull but
i had like a really big okay what happened now recently too
dang oh anything good you'd recommend depends do you like
the sensation of your head bleeding i knew i should have put
prism i'm good all right well for me oh i knew i should have
put prism Like, uh, serenade her.
Do we have enough?
That's charisma, right?
Yeah, that's charisma.
Fuck, I knew it.
I was thinking.
Oh, thank God.
Yeah, we have a lot.
I was thinking that was charisma.
All right, we have an upgrade, too.
You know what?
We'll put you some combat as well.
Won't be bad.
Can't be too bad to be able to fight.
There's some kind of cult recruiting outside my store.
They're creeping everyone up.
Tell them to disperse immediately.
Who's smart enough for that?
I feel like that's...
On it.
Charisma, right?
Wait.
That's charisma.
And what to identify them.
So by identifying, we use our brain.
Yeah?
So...
Well, that's more brain.
Are you kidding?
What?
You don't like her?
Since when?
I'm gonna make you like her.
I think there's also some kind of cult recruiting outside my
store.
They're creeping everyone out.
Why don't you like her?
Don't mess with perfection.
Alright, that's fine.
That's fine.
We don't need it.
Melvonia.
Free their minds.
I feel like that's intelligence.
Destroy their lives.
I don't know what freedom of minds would be the the brain
but I don't think I don't think I have enough I don't think
I have enough guys because like it's I have four I feel like
destroy would be combat right I have enough for combat oh
thank god yeah I was gonna say that's right burn the books
That's right!
Burn it!
We don't need their bug.
For some kind of fight club.
Shut down the underground fight club.
Anticipate resistance.
Alright.
You can fight.
Oh shit.
Yeah, you fight.
I think you guys are good friends, right?
You know what?
We can get two.
We don't need three.
Whatever you say, boss.
Fight in that fight club.
I still think this is a waste of time Don't worry, guys
We'll watch this fight happen I'm gonna bet with for my team
Protect the subscriber while he has lunch Be prepared to
fend off any incoming attacks I mean, last time we got
golden No cash, no kill Wait, what?
SDN's always paid on time and in full So as long as the
check's clear I will kill or protect Alright, there you go
Our men are going Whoopin, man?
I feel like these two.
Go with them with Invis?
Why?
What's up, big guy?
Hey, what's up, little lady?
Yeah, look at it.
They have Synergy?
Oh, that's why.
I don't think he's gonna make it.
Oh, yeah, no, 100%.
Thank God.
I'm on it.
We won the fight club.
We did it guys.
We won All right, that's a hundred.
Let's go.
How'd you manage this one?
I don't want to talk about it.
I've learned from my sources.
Where's she going?
The next tournament will be held at the refinery in one hour
Why in the fight club?
Bro, fight in it.
Robert, send me in to compete.
I'll win so hard.
We'll bankrupt every bookie in Torrance.
Bro, let's do it.
You're so right?
Don't worry.
Give me a sec.
in this.
Wait, what?
You're a training.
Learn to fly.
Well, officially.
Legally.
Your flight-capable heroes need a flight license.
That's fine.
Go to a fly school.
No, we don't need to use coffee yet.
See, I told you.
And he had him.
Four, four.
It's five.
Bro, he is bored to fight.
You can't get hurt.
And we can win money, too!
This whole leaderboard thing goes away.
money but how do you think they feel about menacing threats
let's go let him do what he wants desperate fucks oh did he
got his license lamblay flies greatly reducing oh nice that
reduces travel time my client requires protection at the
torrent's pier prepare to protect the subscribe wait who did
i do calf for that Him, these two, right?
Fucking rocks.
You think your son was on your court or maybe a coup help
punch up?
Alright, yeah, help him out.
Fuck it, let's go.
25.
Uh, what?
This is our 25th time being paired together.
Let's go.
I am.
And then, with me there, welcome to Lindsay's Center.
Get in the air with the bone zone.
Participate in a friendly debate.
I know who to do.
It's on my radar.
Yeah.
Fuck it.
These two like each other.
Oh, my God.
These two.
I always forget.
I've got better things to do anyway.
Wanna dance?
They're okay with each other, right?
I think they are.
Oh, Sonar and Mel?
Oh, that's fine.
There you go.
I keep forgetting who they're friends with.
Oh?
Sorry.
Don't worry.
We got...
Invisigirl here.
Fuckers didn't even see me coming.
Oh, the sabotage is over?
Does it happen again?
Do they ever sabotage again?
Put your position at the top of the leaderboard.
Don't be jealous.
I took a little peek at your file.
Apparently you've got more fire than anyone else on the
team.
I'm like a psychic, man.
I can sense where they're going to be before they happen.
Listen, listen, there's a lot of potential here for a good
health insurance scheme.
Wait.
You just need a middleman.
i could be your guy interesting we did it we won fight club
let's go we got bonus checks oh hold up hold the fuck up
punch i told look at that guys we got we got bonus check
it's the christmas bonus early oh punch up's got a uh
special technique real classy stuff maybe if you ask nice
i'll tell you about it my lips are sealed well look at that
I knew it I knew we can get oh plus synergy oh nice a hero
training I got some who needs extra training what does it do
wait we'll just wait a little bit urgent care on big field
street go quickly oh don't underestimate him he hits hard
okay we need to figure this out
new abilities oh i see okay half man half bad all freak wait
who has new upgrades oh wait we'll grab more combat because
you are a fighter oh god there's a lot help i am at the
torrent's bank and there's these guys with masks and guns oh
god oh god okay
we'll give you prism right uh i don't know i want to we'll
give you some stuff um oh everyone is not oh okay we're
gonna have to put some coffee for someone why can't i use
this oh shatamini okay whatever um Oh, no.
It's okay.
I still have time.
Okay.
No, no way I'm doing that.
What?
On my way.
Are you see?
Okay.
I think you can do it.
Brace yourselves.
I don't think he needs anyone.
All right.
Oh, you're just gonna get cut.
Fuck it, I'm cutting you.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, this is bad.
I already tangled with this dickwad once.
Send someone else.
All right, this is fine.
Thundercock.
All right, trap the robbers.
It's okay.
We got good luck, Golem.
You can solo this.
Golem, sweet.
I believe.
It's a golem sweep.
Okay.
There you go.
Oh, that is...
Oh, now I get why you guys said it gets harder.
That is weirdo.
Oh, my God.
I don't remember.
What is the last one?
Guys, no!
No!
Guys, what was...
Oh my god.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, we got this, we got it.
Okay, okay, okay, we got it, we got it.
We got it.
Yay!
We're a team, everyone.
This is a team game.
Happy!
I believe he can solo this.
This is...
I still believe.
My call is about to the prism creates an illusion that
keeps...
For a few more, this happens.
Prisms now have the full stats of the copy.
Oh, I like that.
I think he can solo this.
My man golems got it.
got him
oh man oh man it's okay that it's all right pretty
breathtaking work back there not too shabby you know it's
not our fault it's like we're working for failures as a team
uh-huh baby that's got a name it's teamwork isn't that like
a sex thing what type of sex thing would that be It's her
fault.
Alright, nice.
Intelligence.
Oh, damn, boy.
That's some fucking teamwork, alright.
Yeah, let's give him word.
Invisigaw, where are you going?
It's not my fault.
What's going on?
Is she depressed?
Because I'm going to keep fire her?
Smoking in a playground.
The fuck's wrong with you?
There you go.
One more strike against me.
You gotta get rid of somebody, right?
I'm making it easy.
for you no you're quitting you're not making it easy for me
yeah why is she smoking of asthma you don't get it some
people are born to be heroes I'm not one of them I tried
just wasn't meant to be meant to be even try that hard oh
you didn't even try that hard flying through the sky nothing
to hide what's your point that was a freaky conversation I
Fucking villain powers I can turn invisible and skulk in the
shadows Yeah, but you can give in to and watch famous people
fuck and villain is my fate I watch you can just film it.
It's in the fucking stars.
And then sell it in the same way that blonde blazer was
always meant to be a hero It is bullshit It's bullshit.
This is something we cling to because we think we're the
main character of life.
Oh, I shouldn't have said that We're a bunch of flesh blobs
with depression on a floating rock Is that supposed to be
comforting?
Yeah, because no one's paying attention if you want to
switch things up.
You've already been a hero, okay?
You have no idea what I'm dealing with.
Oh, get out of here.
At least you were born with powers.
I don't have shit.
So according to your dumbass theory, I should be an
accountant.
You aren't far off.
Fate, destiny, not having powers.
She's into it, guys.
Me talking down on her.
I'm being a hero before.
and they won't keep me from what's that weird where you
compliments you insult them and then compliment them being a
hero again it's working on her i'm in oh it's him again my
god you want to talk about fate that lightning struck fuck
that's been on a spree is two blocks from your location
maybe it's third yeah i'm doing backhanded compliment i'm
out you really want to let you get one over on you a third
time what makes you think it would be any different you're
pissed i get it you know what i like to do when i'm pissed
punch things often bad people i do like to punch things i
know you're great at it go be great one more time yeah and
if you kill him that's a bonus one less criminal on the road
subject kids to secondhand smoke
don't do it don't fucking get that kid a cigarette what's
the address shut the fuck up okay Sorry, I know it's like my
immersion, but that reminded me I was like walking down the
street one time And I think it was I think it was
Valentine's Day, I think and I was walking down the street
to buy some Buy some stuff for dad and I think I forgot to
tell you guys the story But this kid like walked up to me
and was like can you buy me alcohol for like my girlfriend
and I for that Like he was holding like a he was holding
like I didn't give a child holding like a like like a bunch
of flowers like bouquet of flowers and this kid went up to
me and was like can you buy us buy me alcohol for me and my
girlfriend for valentine's day
i don't know how old he was i was like i'll pay you i'll pay
you back but like like i'll give you like i'll give you like
double the money you can buy me for he
said no but that's what it reminded me of like I said no I
didn't want to get arrested like bro we were like it was day
it was day outside like I'm probably not gonna fight this
kid I don't know how old he is like I if I said yes I would
have not told this story on stream because that's me
admitting to a crime live on stream like
Of course I didn't fucking do it.
Why the fuck would I admit it on stream if I did?
But that's just what that's what they provided me of.
I don't know how old he is.
Like, he was like, I know he was underage.
Not underage, but you have to be.
Yeah, yeah.
Because in Canada, it's 18.
So he was definitely underage.
rage.
So if he's asking me to buy him alcohol.
Chad will remember that.
Where's your boy?
Shit.
Because like in America, it's 21, but Canada's 18.
So I was like, that's worse, you know?
You donut girl.
You sure you want to do this again?
He wasn't even going to pay you.
No, he was going to give me money first.
I mean, I could have just taken the money and just...
left got him he's at your five o'clock it's not fair that
you can see me but i can't see you
i i'm i'm flying blind here i can't see anything going on
great give me a second to tap into this oh the hack again oh
it's not time though this time
god i'm laughing out of stress a little more tricky sure
take your time what i need quiet oh i was like so confused i
was like what is that there was not enough time for me to
what is it antivirus there you are okay now there's
antivirus too
got it i can see again that makes one of us four minute
crime i should press why there's something she's not telling
us god thank you in the super chat thank you thank you okay
now we gotta be smart yeah
if i okay i guess i could do this too shit shit shit oh i'm
fucked okay nice jk i'm gaming jk i'm still gaming ignoring
what i ignoring me fucking that up
he's at your seven that wasn't so hard was it he's heading
your way
like and this guy like got a plan oh shit more oh i can only
be caught once i guess oh what
okay fuck you fuck you fuck you fuck you okay nice
oh my god there you go i gotta use my brain for that i
looped him looped the loop on the headlights which should
temporarily blind him giving you a chance to take him out
one two three nice see I saved her life now she'll remember
this oh shit choke him yeah got this break his neck
I'm no hero.
Fuck, no, let me try that again.
Did you see me?
Wait, uh, what about...
Move, let me retry this.
Nice.
That's the one.
Would have been better if you said it first.
Right, just lightning thunder.
Just cut it.
Just edit it out.
Like how Mr. Beast edited his teeth.
You guys know that?
That's crazy.
What is it called?
Teeth gate?
Hey, bangle ball.
more like bangle bitch or bitch boy hey bangle bitch boy
fuck you yeah catchphrases aren't easy guys it takes a while
to build your catchphrase why are those assholes not being
assholes isn't this what you were going for yeah they're
cheering for their teammates so this one keeps the comm line
one on one this one connects to the whole team and this one
goes out to the your brain oh good job yeah you got off
light one dispatcher broadcast the details of his botched
circumcision hr nightmare wait but nobody stopped me you
really think she has a shot nobody went up to me sounded
good but everyone has a shot no if you were just saying what
you thought she needed to hear see i'm i'm nagging yeah
everyone has a shot people are who they choose to be if
invisigal wants this she has to commit it's too easy to quit
when you're good at something now i just got compliment
golem next and now he and now they're like deeply indebted
to me hot and cold guys this mission was textbook genuinely
dude i'm really happy for you so it's between sonar and coop
what so right cool and visigal still at the bottom of the
board oh the one in the bullpen that thing updates every
hour and visigal moved up catching lightning struck really
gave her a huge boost bangle boy really the donut shop
escape slipping past a malevolah now the jewelry store
really bumped up the wanted levels that's like missing the
free throw on purpose to get the putback yeah exactly i
don't watch football but i get it bro i already invested
guys i already invested so much on sonar guys on the bottom
i'm not sure i'd have let you cut her then it's a good thing
she's not yeah so These two are now tied for last place.
Guys, there's the thing is, I gave Koop nothing.
I gave Charlie all my stats.
I support it all the way.
Wait, wait, wait.
The person I pick is the person I'm cutting, right?
I just want to know.
I need to know.
Whoever I'm choosing is the one I'm cutting.
I need to know in case I accidentally fuck it up.
whoever i'm picking is whoever i'm keeping but we all know
who we're keeping because 2025 is his year guys 20.
if i'm honest she still feels a little evil yeah it's too
bad all right i'll get started on the paperwork 2025 is his
year guys feels important hey uh robert gotta end the cycle
great work
Hoop, I'm sure you already know why I've asked you here.
You would be mistaken.
Oh, okay.
Um, well, I'm letting you go.
You're at the bottom of the leaderboards, I guess all those
penalties for, you know, cutting people, added up.
I'm sorry.
But I cheered for Invisagal.
You did.
I saw that.
We all cheered.
I only did that because I thought she was being cut.
Whoa.
That makes sense.
A lot of sense, actually.
Yeah, well, She snuck past her with her last dispatch.
Oh.
That's, uh...
Oh, look at that.
That's very menacing.
Well, thank you.
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
Maybe there are other superhero agencies out there.
You know?
Maybe there's other agencies that she can sign up for.
It can't be only one.
Right?
I just keep that.
You accessorizing?
You could call it that.
Where'd you get that?
Coop.
It's not bad to fire a heart ex-accessant, right?
One is just the bat.
The other one was an ex-accessant.
So I don't know if I made the right choice, guys.
You're spoiling him.
Now, sir, talk about it.
You ready to go home, bud?
Oh,
nothing bad will come out of this, I'm pretty sure.
Who's the bottom now?
Ah.
She's like, yeah.
Where is she on the...
Oh, she's third last.
Guys, as not, like, we're taking a picture of.
I'm third.
Guys, I'm third last.
Let's go.
Okay.
i'm sorry like you're like oh not last not last not last
let's go
big chungus i want i want work for big chungus though
like everyone's like oh and i'm like why the is she taking a
picture
Okay, her being last is sort of, like, her fault, though,
because she was self-sabotaging herself, so...
You in 64, yeah, no one cuts Charlie.
Oh, this.
You in 23% of players kick Golem.
Why did you guys...
Oh, you guys are too soft.
You are all too soft, man.
We're teaching him a fucking lesson.
You're all too soft.
Okay, it helped.
Who the fuck did not help me?
Wait.
Oh, if you don't help her, you get to keep both of them,
right?
Wait.
The other one was...
Wait, who the fuck?
Wait, does it mean, like, if you don't...
Oh.
Oh, if you failed the hacking.
Okay.
So all of you are Phoenixes.
You and a player said fate is bullshit.
Oh, but that was a good choice, though.
I said a good thing.
You helped him escape with no energy two times.
You and 18% of players said, punch up my crew.
You successfully protected victory.
That's funny.
What?
None of you guys fucking joined the fight club?
Guys, we got Christmas bonus now, chat.
I can't believe it.
Your most sent hero is so now you perform better.
Yay, average.
Yippee.
You made him solo it.
Oh, you solo.
Oh.
Because nobody talks about Viqlo.
What?
Wait.
Oh, shit.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Oh, whoa.
We mama.
Ah.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
Is that me?
Oh, shit.
Oh,
fuck.
Oh, okay.
It was a dream.
Okay.
Oh.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, all right, oh my god.
I, oh my gosh.
Guys, this is why, okay.
Yeah, no, no, fuck, okay.
People are like, you gotta put the sensor on.
You gotta, you gotta not use the sensor.
I, I, I don't know how the fuck I could get got away with
that.
I, oh my gosh, okay.
I'm glad I'm glad I put the sensor on I'm glad
This is why the game is popular Psycho.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't remember guys we get all of this
What the fuck Guys we get all of all I don't know what it's
censoring Oh my god, we get all of that but yet The models
aren't public they hit the models
Coop was a friend of his they used to date My last
girlfriend was taller than me she used to kiss me on my
forehead a lot.
It was nice What are we talking about?
Oh Poor dad The problem with only cutting one of them is now
you got to deal with their pissy friends poisoning the rest
of the team come on chase it's harmless yeah who doesn't
love an office prank me motherfucker don't even think about
it that's why I would have cut them all started with that
asshole which one invisible gal but she's staring at you she
had a horny dream of me don't you got some dementia to onset
that's why the models are locked bro you can't lock the
models if you're part of the problem
You can tell one of the one who animated that was animating
some stuff on what's it called the Overwatch models.
They want to be the only supplier.
He looks rough.
Oh.
Oh god.
God.
God damn it, water boy.
Yeah, you can tell whoever animated that was an SFM
animator.
Hey, I was watching that.
They regret it not adding more scenes like that.
They were super chat.
Thank you.
And good thing, because it's the only reason anyone gave
your sorry ass a job.
Water boy used.
To be fair, water gun is basically that.
It's Jesus.
Yeah, I understand.
Protopulse test 7.
Pilot ready.
We good out there?
That's crazy that I'm testing it myself.
Like, what if it fucking explodes?
System power.
Simple locomotion.
Complex locomotion.
Like, what if the thing explodes?
We onto something, bro.
You know what?
Let's do jumping jacks.
This is gonna be it.
Let's go.
That's intensive as hell.
One, two, three.
four five my best subject bro if i can't even do jumping
jacks this shit is fucked
bro can't even pass the e-class
protopulse test seven failure no worries we'll get there
Royd, what is all this stuff?
The whole network expect me to process all the confiscated
stuff.
Because we the bottom branch for SDN, we catch all kinds of
shit work, bro.
Bro, she's checking out my flat ass.
We take one bad guy's stuff and use them for catch the other
bad guy.
Only good thing?
A lot of upgrade possibilities.
You ever jerk off in this thing?
Why do you want to know?
You should really be asking how often.
I gotta work on this.
Maybe I have.
Maybe I haven't.
What's it to you?
Just want to know why the buttons are sticky.
What the fuck?
She's joking, Royd, and her very specific off-putting way
that she jokes.
Oh, she's so into me.
Oh, she likes it.
She likes the bad thing.
Bro, she likes it.
She likes that bad thing.
Some other place.
I got work.
Yeah.
Robert was just leaving.
Look at that tension.
That's gonna be tough.
Because Blazer sent me to get you like half an hour ago.
So Roy will remember this, but he doesn't want to.
I'm forcing him to remember this.
Whoa!
Shit.
Blazer, sorry.
You know what?
I can come back.
Oh no, don't worry.
I got this thing tonight.
But you're still wearing a mask?
This isn't why you're here, but can you zip me up?
Oh, sure.
It's not mine.
By the way, they make me wear it, and it's back in a bag by
midnight.
What is happening today?
Yeah.
What's happening today?
The thing you're going to.
SDN sponsoring a dinner gala thing.
Radiant valor, a night of triumph.
Why does that sound like a propaganda rally?
There.
Thank you.
Yeah, it does kind of sound like some sort of fascist thing.
themed prom what do you think someone was like secret
identities by fucking you have your hair sticking out and
yet the bottom half of your face and your eye you can see
the eyes you're not hiding anything oh hey there's a nipple
out your ariola is showing no cause for alarm but a little
bit of your uh ariola is out it's like a slight hue shift oh
you might as well take that mask God.
You look incredible, girl.
I think you look incredible.
Thanks.
I was supposed to be going with him, but I don't think he's
going to be making it.
The downtown branch dropped him indefinite suspension.
What?
Is that your car?
And why did they drop him?
That's gonna be a weird insurance claim.
I'd like for you to talk to him.
Why me?
You're the pep talk guy.
You've been through a transition recently yourself.
I think he could use some perspective.
Like perspective to join the Z team?
Chase mentioned it.
Yeah.
The only candidates that make sense are him or Waterboy.
And at the moment, it's close.
Yeah, but he could drown himself in...
Mostly, I'd like you to get him out of the parking lot.
He can drown himself in work.
the edible arrangements he keeps sending them but with all
melon that's disgusting oh i'll see what i can do might as
well just send the strawberries i mean i'm allergic to
strawberries but i know that people from what i'm told
strawberries taste good i don't know though i'll never know
how you doing bud i have been better robert robertson the
blonde blazer and i have ended
I'm sorry for your, you know, your loss.
It's very abrupt.
One moment we were savoring uni straight from the urchin.
Next moment I'm contemplating flying into the sun.
What's stopping you?
Absorbing all its energy and casting this planet into
infinite darkness.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, no, I thought, okay.
Yeah, no, don't do that.
Yeah, no.
Maybe then I would be free of the torment in my soul.
maybe then I could quiet my mind these I've had those days
I've been there last time I went to a breakup I drank mezcal
I blacked out when I came to I was in a dark void surrounded
by the smell of rot and I was convinced I died and turned
into a zombie turns out I passed out at a urinal and
somebody threw me in a dumpster thank you for sharing that
you are sad enough to understand see we're just whoa think
there is someone else perhaps another lover could be the
cause of all this maybe she met a person i kissed her an
actual person it was me i'm only telling you this because i
don't want you hearing it from someone else yeah i kiss
blazer it was me That's right Before you incinerate me, it's
worth noting I had no idea she was in a relationship This
happened while we were together It just gets worse That's
right Yeah that's right You're a superhero And I'm a normal
guy And then I kissed it To blame for my sadness Maybe but I
doubt it It was me I guess this is something she was
thinking about It was me, Flash I'm not that good of a
kisser Oh, shit.
No, is he actually gonna kill me?
Wait.
And I can't romance him?
Bro, I could have romance her and him.
Wait, am I that of a kisser?
Bro, I have a girl that's having horny dreams of me.
There's no way.
Oh, shit.
Oh.
Aww, I can't even fly.
My kiss check failed.
I rolled a zero.
I didn't even know that was possible.
The dice, like, exploded when I tried to roll it.
I don't think taking a desk job would have me bleeding this
often.
What are you doing here?
I had a dream last night that we were fucking...
Huh?
Usually I don't remember my dreams, but...
Did I...
Was my...
Dick big.
Was it the one where I have a big dick?
Yeah, I'm sure you did.
Nice.
I gotta know.
I'm doing that thing where I imagine being with someone.
Was it above average?
See how it feels, how it looks.
You know, like trying on a dress.
You were there.
I could have been.
I just wanted to know it was above average.
I could be anywhere.
Oh.
Oh, it's God.
Bro.
Really?
you chose to be here really god damn it water boy i try not
to do that don't worry about a water boy bathrooms are for
after your first coffee and picking shrapnel out of your
chest not for whatever this is you ruined this for me i know
i know my apologies
right to thank you the super chat thank you thank you
strawberries and benedro goes hard what do you mean oh hey
okay you want to get fatter let's go oh god you're a mess
i'm a problem
oh hello guys are you ready for work oh we're missing one
person now weird that coop's gone glad you made the cut
though dude imagine if it was coop and busy together.
I imagine Koop and busy all the time.
Help us get this stuff out of the dorm.
Yeah?
You guys do that kind of stuff?
Those that carry the bot lines?
Alright, here.
You got this.
You're strong?
Yeah, I believe.
I've been hearing a lot about some guy named Chad.
I think he's trying to summon a demon.
He's like, punch up his catapest.
Anyway, I'm gonna send him out.
Chad?
Yeah.
Send, join the club.
I mean, I do know where the church is.
I could snoop around.
Let's do it.
Alright.
Send to directly...
Oh, can I send more people?
You know what?
Fuck it.
Aren't you persistent?
Easy enough.
Guess what?
Why do you...
Should I send two?
Or so not?
Oh, you're right.
Forgot they have perfect synergy.
I may not be everyone's taste, but I am...
a lot of people this guy in front of me just drove right off
like any if not rushed them to the hospital okay someone we
can run yeah there you go i follow you didn't come you
didn't do stuff together that's fine helping people is
actually really cool unless it's an annoying person it's
third and seven oh wait actually let's do this let's check
them out oh this is not good oh oh Oh, oh, that's a bruise
to me, right?
That's, that's fine.
That's okay.
Um, okay, reviewed.
Can you look into their tax filings?
Oh, man.
They're definitely up to no good.
Oh, no, they're committing tax fraud?
How could there is it?
That's a crime, guys.
Don't do that.
All right, uh, Admiral, thank you.
Thank you for the rage.
Thank you.
Let's get the charisma up still.
Someone else?
Oh, there you go.
Um...
Do more combat.
Okay.
Remove the troublemakers.
Okay, I'm gonna grab coffee.
And...
Fresh as a daisy.
Alright, there you go.
You too.
I believe.
I believe in you, too.
Okay, fly them to the hospital.
We have a flyer.
Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank God I got the right person.
Don't see it, dude.
Shit.
Why do you need it?
You're in the field.
I just want to make sure it's there.
It's a very nice stapler.
I should upgrade the other stuff now.
This is Jason from nostalgia alley.
Someone just dropped off a box of games of the no.
Search through the inbound and disarm a bomb.
Okay, well.
Where the hell did you go?
Job's not finished, dude.
We need you to bring everything up to our new place.
Unload the heavy furniture and boxes into the new.
Carry the blinds up for flights of stairs.
Who was it that I told to do that?
I don't remember.
Okay, we can wait a little bit.
We'll wait a little bit because I don't have people right
now.
Alright, search through.
Okay.
I mean, you can do that.
I've got the bandwidth.
It's two for one.
Oh, that's true.
Okay, we'll send these two out there.
And then- Yo, Mal, can we check out that ramen shop?
Bro, you get so cranky.
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, I can put my bitch!
Head and over.
How's my hair?
Perfect as always.
Is he not?
Bro, use your special power.
Oh, man.
Oh, there we go.
There we go.
We're doing it, guys.
I'm learning it.
We need you to send somebody else.
This is too much.
We're out of somebody's.
You're going to have to make do.
Okay, we made it.
I fired his ass.
No, no, no, no, no.
Okay, thank God.
We made it.
The level was right.
I knew you guys got this.
This would be a breeze.
I can't believe I'm saying this, but...
Oh.
Um...
Noted.
Can you just hang in there a little longer?
I'll see what I can do.
Which team is hiding the bomb?
Man bomber?
Is this a trick question?
At chat!
What?
The woes inside us?
Okay.
Okay, it's woes.
We're not cheating.
I'm just...
At chat.
Oh, incinerate.
There you go.
I have the guy.
There we go.
We did it.
Oh, thank God.
Enfuego.
Oh, God.
There's so many.
Uh, we'll do vigor.
And then, God, there's so many people.
It's Rory Casey.
One of my teachers called out.
Guys, I don't have enough soup.
I have, we cut someone.
We cut someone, okay?
We have budget cuts, okay, guys.
Teach defense.
assist with reflex there's no talk about coops old crew
being back in town track down rumors asserting the
organization target shoot your whole everyone just relax i'm
sure it's just a very oh we are short-handed i can't believe
it's not is the pay not good i thought the pay was good toss
destroy the remains of toss oh god um we can we can handle
this oh oh wait okay 97 there's no way i lose this all right
that's good sick okay we gotta send one person at a time now
um teach defense drill reflex god fuck okay track that you
got this you can track you go in by yourself i believe that
needs us that i'm on no okay we i'm gonna send prism out
here okay hey actually uh here you got this demo and then
you go teach you have good reflexes you don't but i don't
have anyone else actually i can cut this close all right you
too go teach oh fuck okay oh oh thank god 65 we made it we
made it at all you.
I'll keep you around for more than one reason.
Mobility.
Gotta make you super fast.
Oh, I forgot Prism second.
I forgot her special ability.
Okay.
Really?
Okay, yeah, no fucking shit.
You win some, you lose some.
How is I supposed to know I need two?
okay but i think this is my last stop for the day is that
good interesting we're not done for the day but someone's
gotta go check on coop oh thank god okay we just made it the
baddest we just made it we were good teachers okay now we're
super short oh dozens of youths just started rushing us
what no you're not interesting Wait.
Okay, wait.
He's a mind reader.
She has X-ray vision.
Together they are.
Send someone...
Privacy.
Okay, I think...
Oh, sorry.
Is this SDN?
We need help.
Okay, wait.
Obviously...
No, you're not doing this.
Alright.
She's fast.
You're training.
You know what?
Go do your thing.
I'm investing it all.
My way.
Cool.
Wait, I had another one?
I already, but like, someone called us about it.
a bomb in one of the theaters oh my god bro okay um oh no
protect the couple send someone good at the fusing situation
who is good at i assume prism right i think prism can make
it
when in hybrid sonar sent he will talk his way out of it and
re-attempt the car sonar is immune and his resting okay yeah
we're gonna talk your way out of this all right nice use
that harvard education you got all right locate the bomb and
disarm it are you good at locating maybe these two yeah
they'll be fine that's gonna leave a mark there we go and
then i can oh no it's bad oh thank god okay you have it
you're healed i can wait a little bit i'm gonna get prism in
here Oh?
Which movie theater should we search first, guys?
Oh, is tracking intelligence?
Oh, we are so fucking stupid.
Oh.
It's okay.
He can burn the bomb.
We can burn.
Chat.
Standing alive.
Okay.
Wow, guys.
What a lucky guess.
Oh.
I need punch.
He fucking left.
activate crawl through the vents guys we have zero
intelligence which one is not the I feel like crawl crawl
because I feel like activating requires IQ but we are three
we're good at everything but IQ oh thank god oh thank god we
just made it we're just fast enough that's how we do it down
under ready Okay, we got Prism.
All right.
I'll put you two in here.
Robert, you were the last one to see my stapler.
What was I?
I don't think that's true.
You're the prime suspect.
Oh, come on.
What?
Oh, oh, oh, it doesn't matter.
It doesn't matter.
Let's go.
We did it.
We detained the youths.
Yeah, fuck the children.
We tried to do it ourselves, but then I remembered my motto
in life.
Why do it when you can make someone else do it for you?
Oh, he's smart.
Okay.
That requires a brain.
Wait, we're doing, like, task rabbit here.
What?
No, Phil.
Can you just walk him around?
Walk Phil.
Phil is imposed hard.
God damn it.
Okay, we can wait a little.
That's fine.
Okay, we need someone strong.
Oh, disrupted.
Yeah, we can be in.
Oh, I'll get to the bottom of this shit.
Alright, nice.
I'm glad there's no Grammy for this.
We did it.
mediate it all right so it's time for phil's walk what there
you go phil's my dog can you just like walk him around the
park yeah he's like my dog yeah all right i feel like we
could i can wait a little bit now put malin yeah this seems
fine phenomena man still on the 405 just passed him he's
gone from shaking his fist at cars to sadly directing
traffic well at least he's putting his newfound pain to get
charisma i had no idea blazer was such a heartbreaker is
that surprising but i need vikes bigger i think she had
dinner maybe you shouldn't be so quick to judge are you
smart enough to nice we did it i knew you i knew going to
harvard makes you able to read ikea instructions it's fine
see i told you it's fine Got it, huh?
It takes two to walk a dog.
Robert, I found my stapler.
Where was it?
The immobility.
Actually, the combat.
And...
Guess I can equalize Mal.
I'll put her...
I'll make her more of a all-around person.
Hey, it's Jerry from Comic Pug.
We got a gift of some Mega Man replicas.
Expect the suspicious Mega Man.
mech but with bomb threats i forgot what works with bomb
threats do let's go with bomb threats again why nothing
beats the original but it's fine right we don't need we
don't need vigor i think it's fine we got two in we're doing
pretty good at the real part of the game we only had we
fucked up one thing and that was with punch out and now he's
not there anymore which mecha man contains the bomb what
happens when we fuck up the choice it's like one out of
three and this is a clean ass run all right at chat let's do
a lucky guess guys this is all luck by the way all luck wow
who would wow guys we're so lucky how do we keep guessing
the right mechas chat oh my god we're so smart we just
somehow keep guessing the right ones we're like psychic or
something and that's lunch so lucky oh great i'm gonna drink
my spicy water all right nice we only failed one that's fine
under review i haven't even been paid yet like what oh hey
melon and chocolate
still working on that I love the green ones the the green do
all yours take the whole thing if you want awesome my lucky
day I know what's for lunch or dinner probably now sorry I
interrupted that bake has a nice ass my ass is fat my
initials were literally on the box and everything fuck I
don't read things sometimes it's different like a logo but
it's probably still good I don't What?
The fucking trash noodles.
Wet fart boy.
Whoa, what are you doing?
Whatever.
It was an accident.
Just aim your dick up and water piss it off.
That's not...
You...
To be fair, he wasn't being a really bad janitor, though.
How would you like to have to walk around work the rest of
the day with shit all of you?
I don't know.
I don't think about that.
Because it won't happen.
Because I'm not a fucking idiot food thrower away here.
It was an accident.
You don't have to be a bully about it.
You want this in your report?
Well, are you gonna snitch on me?
Yeah?
Wait, I can't even snitch on it.
There was being a soft bitch about it.
Bully.
How am I being?
In fact!
Oh, wow.
I wasn't expecting it to go straight.
That was extra.
Sorry.
Spaghetti or spaghetti?
You're gonna choke on this fucking...
Hey, Robert, could you...
Spaghetti.
Did you eat my lunch?
Why would you do that?
don't want to be a snitch but flamb was really payback
another hr report i don't even think they have hr well if
you're gonna eat it i wish more of it got into your mouth go
get cleaned up then clean this up then pick me up a blt from
johnny's and we'll call it even yes i'm saying it's that
like okay i feel like working hr for superheroes is like
anyway you don't have enough pay for that Who's it going to
be?
Phenomenon or Waterboy?
And these two are my only options.
For now, yeah.
Obviously, we can revisit it.
But Waterboy is already a trainee, sort of.
And you already know Phenomenon got cut by DTLA.
Thanks for getting him out of the parking lot, by the way.
It might also help to get, you know, an actual good person
on your team, which...
Wait.
Are we cutting someone?
Like, if I pick someone, do I cut, put him?
on my team or uh joining my team okay i'm picking someone
join i am not picking water boy guys i there's no way if
anything phenomena like phenomena as act is a real fucking
superhero like like why i don't bro
I'd rather have a depressed Superman than someone that can't
do anything Like it was at least a depressed Superman We
don't do we don't need another healer Having another healer
implies that I'd fuck up, but I don't fuck up Like Think of
the potential Justice Alright, we flip Alright, we flip a
coin Okay Heads is water boy Tails is a phenomenon We're
Okay, heads or tails heads or tails all right heads is water
boy tails god fucking guys we got phenomenal we're not
getting potential man guys we definitely got phenomenal man
ah okay Okay, how about this?
I'll make a pull.
Water.
Water boy.
Or potential, man.
I don't know how to spell phenomenal.
Potential.
Water boy.
Okay, I'll pick the one who bribes me the most.
JK, never mind.
Whoever, I'm going to use the bathroom.
And whoever bribes me the most gets the pick.
Whoever, whichever character gets the most bribes.
I'll be right back.
Yeah, that's right.
That's right.
We're accepting bribes now.
How else do you think people lobby shit in?
That's right.
We're lobbying.
I'm going to teach you what lobbying means.
I'll be right back, guys.
I go pee.
All right,
I'm back.
Okay.
Keep Phenomenal, man.
Waterpoint lobby.
Waterpoint bribes.
Now, think of that.
super thank you thank you get potential man now i agree
thank you for the chat the super super thank you super man
super thank you thank you alan for uh thank you super chat
thank you thank you face pumpkin thank you with super chat
thank you thank you water boy lobby so very thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you gus thank you for the
akasupa thank you thank you when the building is crumbling
the criminal shooting you don't want piss boy to rescue vote
for now for a brighter tomorrow.
Thank you for the Akka Supa.
Thank you.
Certified.
Ian, thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you.
Okay, guys.
Has anyone been keeping count?
I don't know who's winning.
Water.
Okay, I think Water Boy is winning right now.
Joah, thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you.
Alright.
Water Boy is currently in the lead.
We have lots of Water Boy is currently in the lead right
now.
water boy you can't escape simple mind and think of a super
chat thank you thank you i'm going to do a 10 second
countdown and to see if a nomad man can come in uh and swoop
in for the day all right 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 potential manner
right now please thank you for the akas super thank you
thank you no water boy oh unfortunate water boy i'll it
looks like phenomena man came in at the last second to lobby
your you up sorry as i kindly take uh the donations uh for
my campaign under the table i have decided to go with
potential man he has my vouch I just thought naturally
nobody influenced my decision um I would just took camp I
just took campaign donations guys nothing was going on
anyway I shall now lobby for potential man sleeping thank
you for the magenta soup but thank you thank you all right
all right I love democracy see guys wait potential man is
guys okay greece wait no no no wait greece donated before
and with who he wanted what he has it greece all right did
you want it greece did you want to pretend a phenomena man
or water boy your donation changes the course of time i call
both potential man to be fair greece donation cements
whether or not it's water boy or phenomena man what did
greece say
yeah water is it was it blue for water it greece please
It's a blue doorknob.
Is it blue for water, Grews?
Is it not?
Water, boy.
Blue for water.
I gotta be sure.
It's phenomenal.
Or is it his depression tears?
I gotta be sure.
Because your vote, your vote is the one that changes it up.
blue he said it's phenomenon it's depression man guys i
don't know if you're fucking with me or if that's what he
wants guys he said depression man what if you're making that
shit up it's depression man i positive both of them are
phenomenon i guess i mean i'm worried he has too much time
to think right now that's all right i feel the same way he
could use a distraction so it won't be weird with your it's
water boy i mean he's already hanging around so he may as
well be doing some good instead of moping around the parking
lot crushing cars now we phenomena has won the lobby i'll
let him know you'll see him in the roster for your next
dispatch why would i get man it's okay he can drown his
tears with work justice for water boy it's a fair and honest
vote guys whoa a moment of your time how do you move so
quiet the power of donations if it would make you more
comfortable i could remove my clothes as well it would not
look if this is about in a hard decision oh no need see look
at that should be up doing good but to do good you need to
be doing i don't even watch you i just wanted to ruin the
days of people like water boy like a true good oh i've
reopened your chest wounds do you think you was super
chatting you think yeah
Waterboy tried lobbying Chris.
He just wanted to see the world suffer.
Where is he?
Where's potential, man?
We appreciate you doing your best.
Last shift under the circumstances, but we are here to help.
More specifically, phenomenal.
There he is.
He's gonna be here to help.
Whoops, sorry.
He's gonna be here to help, guys.
five this guy didn't he also get fired yeah listen i know
things have been difficult for him no he got relocated guys
a great addition to the team difficult because you dumped
him busy damn damn the mean child is correct but i think no
i'm glad we picked phenomenon the opportunity to see her
again will make day easier i think you gotta be backwards
bro yeah it don't work that way boy trust me oh you're so
depressed it's great we have reason to believe that mr van
der stank's life will be in danger out of you know what i
got you you know what really want me yeah i got you bro go
in there you no i didn't just get ditched apologies what i
thought i saw a blonde blazer in phenomenal man i'm at the
office these one-on-one seem to read i think i could make
this a regular thing oh who should get it yeah i'll put you
in wait don't worry he's coming in to help out wait did he
help out wait he didn't wait where was he we're a little
down on new subscribers this month i think you can spare
here a cheerful positive attitude budget cuts well then how
the fuck are we supposed to do this you could try charming
them with your winning personality Oh, wait, we have
charisma here.
Yeah, there you go.
Wait, who has more charisma?
Yeah, he has most charisma.
It's fine, we have a clone.
What's this?
After also creates a portal where Alas, where if near the
call, also reveals the stats, the next call she's assigned
to.
Okay, we should do that.
That's fine.
It's okay, we had his clone.
We don't need him.
We have the clone, guys.
Oh my god.
Okay, that's fine.
That's why I know we did it guys.
It's okay.
We have the clone Vanderstank lives to innovate another day.
See look he did his job technically He did something Yeah,
the clone wasn't depressed.
I just gotta pair him up with the good prism With Emily of
all season It's a charming and good-looking hero Physicality
is valued in addition to looks
Phenomenal?
Do they like depressed?
Are they okay with depressed men?
Like...
I'm just, I'm wondering if he's depressed, is that okay?
Like, like some women will want to fix him, right?
Like, that can work.
With more charisma.
Okay.
Let's see.
On it.
I don't know.
Who's more...
Who's...
Mel or...
Lambay?
Yeah, he does have Bay in there.
Okay, let's grab Combat 2.
No, I don't think Punchy's gonna do it.
Prism?
Mal?
I feel like...
Waterboy had all the charisma.
Oh.
Okay, Charming...
I think like Mal.
I mean, look at Mal.
What would your job be?
I feel like working at a gas station would be pretty chill.
Nice, we got it.
Yeah, right.
You hate pets.
I hate pets with bad attitudes.
What pets have good attitudes?
Snakes.
Snakes?
I guess so.
They're just chill.
Every snake is chill.
You just sit there.
I have recently learned of the American opossum.
I find it fascinating how it carries its children's heart.
Much like a bus.
Yeah, what the fuck is he talking about?
Possums aren't pets, man.
I see.
That's not true.
You can technically any animal can be...
No, actually, don't do not.
No, no, no, no, no.
Wait, don't quote me on that.
Don't quote me that.
I'm not...
I'm not in for exotic animals, guys.
Not all pet...
Guys, no, no, no.
All pets can be...
Not all animals can be pets, guys.
That is it.
Not all animals can be pets.
Guys, I don't want to get in trouble.
uh make fight the mascot during half time make it look
convincing but pull your punches maybe these two do i need
intelligence for that like do i gotta make it look smart
whatever i wasn't sure about it either i don't know that
you're trying to tell me something but
I don't know if you need intelligence for that.
You need combat.
Yeah, I feel like I need...
You know, I'll put Kodam in here.
We can do it.
I don't know.
Depends on the dirt.
Oh, hacking time.
Ah, you lucky bastard.
Hacked into the computer.
Oh, it's no difficulty.
I got this.
That's for babies.
Look at that.
What's this?
Okay, I gotta get a key for that.
Okay.
Oh, oh, oh wait, I'm timed.
Oh, I was not paying attention.
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Oh, this is hard.
Okay, we got this.
Right, right, down.
Okay, right, right, right, down.
Oh, what?
Oh, shit.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, oh.
They said it was low!
Right, right, down.
Okay.
I gotta block him off?
No!
Okay, last chance.
Okay.
Right, right, down.
Like that?
Oh!
Okay.
And then I could do this.
right right down right right right okay guys remember look
at this okay give me the right password what's the right
password guys i i didn't right right down right right down
left left up left left up what right right right down wait
left left up right right down oh Left, left, up, right,
right, down.
Oh, God, this is not good.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no!
No!
I didn't realize the other guy was here!
Security.
We?
I couldn't get past their security.
These are two sides.
No!
Why are you depressed?
I should be depressed!
My outside was always so serious.
strong okay that's fine sure fine that's fine a symmetrical
stage picture robert i am sensing dissatisfaction amongst my
new companions i don't know is one of the powers stating
this super obvious you did one job indicator no wonder blaze
this is what happens you said you wanted to help i got you
one of the best heroes at sdm the best at pissing everyone
off yeah yeah the best at The best they're leaving a giant
crater.
Guys, stop!
He won't keep himself safe!
Stop!
He needs to keep himself safe, guys!
I captured a small, it may be a little, but it's so strong.
Um...
I think Golden can do it.
You knew me?
Fucking rocks.
Nice.
I'll put both of you guys in there.
Am I a kajoo?
Okay, nice.
100.
I knew it.
I knew we got this.
But convince the boss if all fails.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
You're not smart.
Okay.
Charisma.
Wait, actually, maybe he's returning.
Hello, dispatcher.
Would you like to play a little game?
Perhaps.
What kind of game?
A brain teaser.
I hate this asshole.
Careful.
Oh, adopted.
His name is Brain Teaser.
How tricky can he be?
Oh my god, he's my Riddler.
That's a baby right there.
I know what I gotta do.
Oh shit, you got a new pet.
A new child.
Riddler's meet him.
Teaser meet this, Batman.
I will make her an all-arounder.
Find the brain.
Humor.
Let's humor him.
God!
damn it one two three and i will gladly turn myself in a
wise investment okay okay so the thing is look i know that
he but he has another chance he he okay look at guys the
thing is if he fucks up he has another chance to do it again
guys that's the thing he other option what's the other
option i could also just track you down oh it only works in
okay okay wait but i want to do his riddle
guys but i want to do his riddle though not start a war here
with an elite assassin organization convince your boss you
know what we'll send him these two oh wait we shouldn't
we'll Send in these here.
You know, do you?
Because then they'll have...
Send Prism?
I don't know if I can...
Okay.
I want to do the riddle.
I made some buddies who live under...
Okay, I have time.
And before you ask, yes.
Trump persuaded...
Withstanding the beer bottles, okay, we have nothing.
It's okay.
I have this.
Alright, we...
Actually, we can...
Okay, we can wait a little bit.
We can wait a little bit.
Alright.
Okay, but we don't have enough intelligence, though.
That's the thing.
Wait, okay.
He's gonna do this, and then I'm gonna...
I'm gonna give it to the bat.
There we go.
I just want to wait for him to return.
This is fine.
Oh, my gosh.
Okay.
This is still fine.
No, we invested it all on one guy.
It's fine.
All right, and then he returns.
Half-bath all freak.
He's going to return and he's going to be teaser me this.
There you go.
Hero, go do your thing.
Do your riddle.
It was stand up beer bottles.
Cheer up and persuade.
Okay, we can just do these two.
Oh, he's back.
He's not depressed anymore.
Intercom malfunctioning.
Can anyone hear me?
More intelligence.
All right, there we go.
I believe in depressed, the Phenomenon.
okay we'll start what is my favorite game the wolf within us
i don't know no brainy 1949 the wolves have eyes the wolves
inside us is it the wolves within us that's like the wolves
among us right or the wolves inside us inside us that's a
okay oh oh it's the same what about my oh it's standing
alive right oh yeah yeah yeah alive right yes the bombs I
remember the bombs make a man prime I remember this there
you go yeah okay maybe I okay anybody Jesus Christ come and
get me I've been waiting downstairs in the lobby for at
least 30 what the fuck is wrong with your head?
There's no skull.
He has no skull.
It's just brain.
Time to freak some fuckers out.
Alright.
More intelligence.
Actually, I don't think I need more intelligence, actually.
I think we can chill a bit on that.
I think we can chill a little bit.
Maybe more intelligence is not the best thing.
You know what?
Let's give you intelligence.
You're my all around it.
He was the brain teaser.
Are you aware your entire head is just brain like like you
fucking squish the top of his head and he's dead Like
actually like I like he bumps his head and his fucking
entire brain bleeds he goes into a coma I'm actually making
Batman are you okay that was scary I was gonna Okay I know y
'all saw that don't be jealous it's okay it's okay All
right, nice.
Oh, I didn't really.
Oh, nice.
Just one.
That's the hacking one.
But we don't need to worry about that.
Yeah!
I got here another injury.
Oh, my God.
I swear to God, it was another.
It was another one.
Ooh, it's good with mobility.
I will put it.
We'll put it.
We'll give it to you.
All in.
her because she wants to bang me i do have favorites whoever
is the most horny for me say sad sex son of a bitch but yeah
let's go with yours yeah let's go with mine hey kid love you
mm-hmm whoa you too aren't don't fuck this up
with my dad that's how to get that's right you want a
promotion
that's definitely an hr violation
oh there he is jesus christ every time i see him oh my god
bro hey mom hey honey he is he is like a he's an absolute
unit By that measure, there's an 800k way tie for first.
Thank you for the super chat, Disney.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, he's finally getting his first extra tie.
Same.
It's like, what you want me to do?
Fucking it, loser.
You're crazy.
Fucking crazy.
Oh, it's depression, man.
Also, do they even do superhero stuff anymore?
I swear she just does office work instead.
Earlier that day, Blazer and I had breakfast at the rim of
an active volcano.
Then we made love.
I don't need to hear your sex stories.
We never had intercourse.
My alien genitals were not compatible.
That's cool.
Why is that cool?
It's, uh, it's not.
What were you saying?
She was the only thing I was passionate about.
Her voice, her eyes, her eyes, and disposition.
Her whole of her remarkable corporeal form.
How do you know?
How do you know she's the only thing you're passionate about
if you haven't found anything else you're passionate about?
Exactly.
Your logic with that statement.
You have to laugh so.
Oh, the one she dumped it, bro.
What you need to do is find the next thing for you to be
passionate about.
Because it's out there.
Thank you.
I wish to make a love to you again.
Oh, is that...
But this time, I will avoid squeezing the blood out.
Wait, what?
That's how he fucks?
Bro!
Oh, okay.
Okay.
I did not realize Hugging was...
his form of intercourse.
What you watching?
Technically, you're still on the clock.
Another HR violation right there.
On the clock, you shouldn't be pegging me with anything,
Robert.
That's extremely inappropriate.
Especially since I'm usually the picker.
Oh, he's definitely a hugger.
Well, tell me how it is.
These ESL turkeys don't make fun of him.
forget what i'm watching by the time the movie starts same
you going solo i'm alone or ravi a rebel that night feel bad
asking people to pay when i'm just gonna sneak in the only
lame thing is i can't get snacks floating buckets of popcorn
too tend to draw a lot of attention but i miss it i miss
popcorn just get popcorn just going to the theater oh bro
don't do this to me Are you serious?
Are you fucking kidding me?
You want a bad bitch?
Oh, bro.
You want a bad bitch or a muscle mommy?
That's so hard to pick, man.
The thing is, Invisigal, Visi already showed us what she can
do.
But we haven't seen what Blazer could do, guys.
That's the thing.
like, the thing is, but we haven't, they haven't shown us
what she could do.
We saw what the other girl could do.
like,
oh, like, we, we haven't been shown everything.
Must allow me no question So sad, I'm thinking with a super
chat Don't be greedy But, but like But I love being greedy
Go with your heart Oh, you know, you know what I want if I
go with my heart Because I'm a greedy girl, I'm a greedy
bitch I want it all You know it Alright, time to solicit the
folks Pick Nader.
They're both red flags.
BL, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
People who think Pink Blazer is seeing people who think salt
is spicy.
But we don't even know if she's freaky.
You don't know that.
You don't even know if she's freaky or not.
She never even had.
She never even had the Mecca Man, though.
Guys, come on.
How long has she been dating depression?
man bro you know she's gonna be wild you be wild only got
muscle dragon thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you greens thank you the super chat thank you thank you i'm
here to watch the world burn how much money do you need for
me to make you pick blazer thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you the blaze you know what we'll do we'll
do the polls we'll actually do a poll this time all right
and screw it i'm putting my money where the peg is it's busy
time all right you can't blame me whoever wins wins you
can't who muscle bad i'll let i'll let that people vote i'll
let the people vote Oh, oh, wait, it's close.
It's so close.
All right, to the muscle enjoyers.
Why?
Give your case.
Come on, Blaze.
Blaze is better.
No big fixing her.
Convince your people.
Convince your people, why?
She got no play.
Because of muscle.
Do we even need to explain it?
All I'm saying, guys, all I'm saying is that, bro, she has
been dating Depression Man for how long?
And, like, they never were able to do anything.
So you know, she freaky.
She...
She freaky.
Pia, thank you, my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Chat, muscle dump the sweetheart.
It's phenomenal, man.
Desert, thank you, my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Greaves, thank you, my super chat.
I don't have a case, but it wouldn't be funny.
Thank you, my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You all know.
You all know why we choose here.
Patroescu, thank you, my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm not trying to have a power dynamic when a woman who
needs a man Not someone trying to use it.
I'm trying to have women put the power dynamic on me.
So, Zaya, thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, I snored a lime and wasabi for a night between.
Madwick, thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Doki, Blonde Blazer in comics needs Robert.
Trust, go with Blonde Blazer.
Kaizen, thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
boy do i date my boss or date the person i'm in charge of oh
my okay this is like really bad don't bad in real life but
like do i date guys but if i date my boss there's a more
likely of a chance i get a promotion i the you're true true
the bad girl does have um does have more baggage The power
dynamic is crazy.
Both ways.
I'm just saying one of those girls can fold you in half and
you know which one that is.
Patrick, I said, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, your boss.
And she's going to make you go out in a blaze of glory.
Papa, thank you, but super chat, thank you.
And Vizzy, Martin the best.
P.L., thank you, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Cut, and Vizzy, girl.
And then date her one.
100 percent god damn it guys get that promotion queen thank
you for the magenta sofa thank you thank you ah this is so
hard this is the hardest decision of my life and that's why
i'm letting you guys decide because whatever happens you
guys if you guys fuck it up then it's not my fault uh all
right i will leave the poll up for two more minutes so you
guys better for the indecisive voters.
You guys better shout your case for the indecisive voters
right there.
They're the ones that matter.
They're the ones that will change the tide for all of you.
We already got the poll.
Alright, I'm gonna do a countdown, guys.
I should know.
I'm gonna wait till it hits five.
When it hits five minutes, everyone, then, then I'll pick.
Missy, again.
Rise up.
Guys, please.
Tomboy.
HR violation usually go upwards.
Olly, thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for the five gift of ships.
Vote guerrilla grip.
Vote Vlad Blaser.
Elly, thank you.
Thank you.
Zonderman, thank you.
Supercheck.
Thank you.
Tomboy.
How is that even a oh my gosh these are such hard decisions
in life i'm glad i don't have to make this decision i'm i do
think the muscle mommy and joyous are more vocal i think the
the bad bitch the tomboy the tomboy lovers are like the
silent majority
they are they are they are like the silent majority right
there they might not talk as much but but they will but they
will come out and vote when it needed
all right it's five minutes I'm sorry I'm sorry muscle
enjoys I know I know how much you wish we could you wish you
could get bent in asked by her uh but oh my god i almost
pressed her on but it looks like it looks like we're going
with the with the tomboy
i didn't see the first one can you give me a recap it's
against the law for you to be watching like this actually
it's illegal for you to be filming i don't need the whole
thing just enough to know what's going on okay it's about
this struggling act who gets this big roll from a movie star
and a mistake.
The dragon loons can't be bot democracy one.
Thank you for the super chat, Barrett.
Thank you, thank you.
Then he realizes her secret, but it turns out he has a
secret too, which could ruin.
Oh, shit, there's sour patch.
Hey.
You didn't hear any of that?
Yeah, no.
It's probably fine, though.
So, what are we, like, friends now?
Or is this some sort of team building exercise?
I thought we already were To be fair, I thought we already
were.
Oh, that's embarrassing.
Oh, would have been nice to know before I spent 86 bucks.
I'm not gonna fuck you just because you bought me a bucket
of corn Who said I was gonna fuck you?
Can you just be normal for like a second?
Who said who said I was gonna fuck you?
I just bought popcorn I just must have bought me for you.
This is not nice what are you gonna say do you like sour
patch kids i didn't choose wrong she laughed sour patch kids
look at that oh look at that didn't it up i'm in also yeah
yeah no i'm not surprised it's a movie theater they gouged
those branches i'm surprised it wasn't a hundred bucks
Bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom, bottom.
Ah man, I didn't fuck up that decision.
I knew I didn't fuck it up.
All right.
You are in 487 for 7 players.
Oh my God, the majority added water for it?
All right, how many people?
Oh man, I guess tomboy lovers were the majority.
You and Warren, you and 35% of players confess to kissing
blonde blazer.
I'm right, I did.
You and 20% saved all three businesses.
Yeah, I did it.
Oh, wait, I'm so smart.
You and 25% players correctly canceled all three.
I did it.
Toki, I regret my vote.
Can you go back to muscle, mommy?
Super chat BL.
Thank you.
Oh shit.
Wait, I fucking nailed this one.
You performed better at 10% players.
I nailed it.
You will carry the weight of your decision.
You knew what you, you, you have to carry this weight for
the rest of your life.
Ah, I don't know about you to do another episode.
I'm having fun.
Oh my god.
No, I nailed it.
Look at this.
You performed.
Oh
All right, one more.
I'll do one more.
I'll do one more up
I'm having fun.
I'm having fun
Oh, is that the bitch you plop forever?
Okay, okay, I'm gonna I I would end it with that I'm I'm
content with ending it with that one
That's everybody all clear It's eight episodes Mecca man,
it's one name I wish you learn how to read that day is very
far from now mr.
McCluff again.
So you would super chat anything Yeah, oh
Shit Fast ass runner.
Why am I not buff for all the exercise I do?
Damage is done All I want is a conversation Oh No need to do
anymore.
Oh, oh flamb
Is it all cardio?
Oh,
that's true I was in a coma.
I forgot about that.
There's a code of a famous V2 or something, but Asia map and
bananas.
Guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Matt, thank you for the super chat thing.
Now he's doing like, now he's putting on, doing muscle gain
stuff.
The 165 with that frame?
Bro, he doesn't even have a spotter.
He's so he's so fucking stupid That is how you fucking break
your chest
Yeah, he's like benching solo you're not supposed to live
without a spot exactly You you do not have superpowers you
weak Now I'm getting a safety lecture from a walking
fireball it's a reality check normies need babysitters so
you don't hurt yourself thinking you're a hero man I am so
fucking strong yeah I'm not normie I watch anime put up more
on the bench no more hero stuff without supervision you
can't get injured because we need you behind that desk to
help real heroes actually speaking of injuries remind me who
took your tooth um it's like they only stole that little bit
i got to do a fight with an actual real actual hero and i
assure you he's regretting his decision to tangle with me
i'm into gundam okay bro this is how he gets his ass and you
it's time for you to accept that you don't got it anymore
and pretending you still do is bombing people the Now, get
your flat ass off my bench.
This is so true.
Bro, his ass is so fucking flat.
You know, this squad like that bay.
Many.
Aw, look, he got me a gift.
Bro, that bay.
Bro, you know, you know, you've been squatting for another
reason.
Like, that ass can, like, that ass got kicked.
Okay.
Oh, treats are work.
All right.
Oh, you ever noticed the Torrance vibe is like...
Rancid?
Between the dead fish in the harbor and the giant refinery,
it can't tell who's to blame.
Dang, that's some nasty shit.
Man, I love the smell of the refinery.
I hate the smell of gasoline.
I love the smell of gasoline.
Yeah, we going in.
We're clocking in for my nine to five.
Who pissed in your cereal?
Now that's some nasty shit.
Oh, let's do this.
All right, we sent Depression Man in first.
Torrance Middle School needs judges for our annual talent
show.
Do it for the kids.
Okay, I'm sitting prism in.
I can't trust you.
Actually, no.
We're going to find three slots.
So magnetic personality, Charlie.
Okay, hustle.
And it's good with kids.
I think Charlie can handle it.
He doesn't need anything else.
Do you ever feel like you had so much potential and you're
being wasted as a cog in a corporate machine?
Do not send crypto, bro, in.
I'm going to teach the kids crypto.
I'm going to trap after a tunnel collapse at the new
station.
Get them out safely.
All right, this is it.
Discreetly.
There we go.
Depression man.
No problemo.
There you go.
I believe.
Is this man familiar with ethical?
All right, there we go.
There you go.
Depression man.
He's going to do it.
I think Charlie is very good with kids.
He's a business genius.
Everything he does is brilliant.
There you go.
See?
Let's go!
The kids know crypto now.
Jesus, kid.
Let's go.
Isn't this like the third time one of his projects has
fallen apart?
But speed is key.
Oh, okay.
We have more like...
We're literally maxed out on speed.
There's no way.
Yeah, I was gonna say, we're 10.
Too bad there's no Grammy for this.
You monster.
Oh, it's this.
The parents started fighting over the results, and then the
kids joined in too.
Convince them non-violently, please.
Okay.
Oh, no, I don't have charisma.
I can wait a little bit.
They're resting.
It's fine.
What's this?
inclusive workplace make you a great sponsor for our aliens
among us exhibit this looks like a job for Phenomenon who is
me yeah but you don't you don't look like an alien I'm gonna
send in I'm gonna I'm gonna send in man bad oh shit he's a
natural bat right now okay That's fine.
Training time.
Oh, send it.
That's true.
It's training time.
If anyone's up for it.
Yeah, but he doesn't.
What if he doesn't show up?
Guys, what if he doesn't show up?
Yeah.
I got a coupon for a free.
All right, I'm sending it.
But if he doesn't show up for the kids, I swear to God.
So don't tell her nothing.
I remember my first talent show.
creates a slot exclusively for him to join.
I'm gonna ask you about Lizzie Galupo.
Second place.
Impossible.
I'm gonna stop, call, okay, we'll do that.
I got her back though.
I shot a laser beam and burned all that hair off.
So, I guess you're the real winner then?
Sure am.
Inspired my- Oh wait, tell them about- oh wait, there you
go.
Oh my god, it worked.
Sounds like a real bop.
Never say bop again.
Look at that, see?
Not so depressing now.
Is it?
Look at that.
Can't be that bad.
I, dear Drazy, yes, that dear Drazy, need help make him
disappear.
Oh my gosh, I don't have smart people in my team.
I don't know why.
I think I only have one person in my team that's smart.
Oh, this is so bad.
Are you fucking?
Okay, thank God.
Okay.
Thank God.
I wonder why.
Why did I go all in on the Harvard graduate?
Is anyone smart?
Three, three, three.
Okay, maybe.
Okay, we're sending in.
I'm sure to increase this.
I'm going to increase her intellect.
And then I'm going to fix her.
Florence Middle School is hosting an anti-bullying seminar.
And it would mean a lot.
Oh, my God.
Why are they...
The students and their parents.
Don't matter.
Okay.
Together, the two of us will be unstoppable.
Okay, it's fine.
I bet you say that to everybody.
It's fine.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna give coffee.
Feeling fresh.
Her, and then...
Um...
I think this will work.
You know what?
Perfect as always.
Let's put them together.
I'm on my way.
I know, like, maybe he'll...
Man back with Sona's gonna scare people, but that's okay.
You miss a rabies shot or something?
Power was out at my place.
Couldn't even check up on my investments.
Oh no, the numbers that go up and down every day.
You'll be fine.
Survey restraining order.
Okay, do you think I can delete all the files in time?
I think I can do it.
I doubt Deidre is the only victim of this.
Let's delete all the files on his laptop.
I believe in myself.
Get the backups too.
And the backups too.
Okay.
Right, right, left.
Guys, what is...
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay, okay, it's fine.
Left, left, right.
Left, left, right, left, left, left, right, left, left,
right, left, left, left, left, left, left, left, left, left,
left.
Left, left, left, left, left, left, left, left, left.
Left, left, left, left, left, left, right, left, left, left,
left, right, left, left, left, left, left, left.
Left, left, right.
Left, left, left, left, left, right, left, left, left.
Left, left, left right.
Guys, guys, what was it?
Right, right, right, left.
Right, right, left.
No!
Right, right, left,
left.
Okay, there you go.
There you go.
I was panicking, I was panicking, I was panicking.
I was panicking.
Yay!
Was this that hard?
Jesus, I deleted it all from the cloud.
Wasn't even that hard.
Oh my god.
Oh, that was close.
My might is your might.
So easy.
The set needs a background actor for an upcoming scene.
The last one stormed off in a hurry.
Break a leg, but not like that.
that okay we need charisma I guess hair this is fun oh wait
I'll wait oh wait we did it guys it wasn't even that hard
hey we're getting flooded with calls about sewage in a
couple neighborhoods what should we hit first okay wait but
I couldn't get her in bam here I go there we go sewage spill
there's poo the sewage spilling out venturing into the
sewage repair that broke withstand the sheer force i feel
like if it's withstanding and like here yeah you could go in
there phenomenal man is probably the most bullyable on z
team now i am often bullied for my exquisite hair and
beautiful masculine frame there we go see look at how much
work he's doing phenomenal man my form is let me go
Disgusting.
Oh god, that was so close.
You look great.
Roberts is bullying me.
Please ask him to stop.
What the fuck did I do?
Fucking try to cure your goddamn depression Are you oh,
that's close.
All right, 97.
Nice.
We saved the beach Hope this makes it a little easier.
Yay Beach has been saved.
All right, I'm gonna put more intelligence onto my people
Like I we can't rely on Charlie.
What I found out was relying on Charlie on all the IQ tests
Might be specific type of hero for my upcoming.
Oh, a mysterious send someone unassumably strong.
Oh um Oh Man That's okay.
Give me a sec Maybe golem I think golem
He's...
Yeah, but he's not that strong, guys.
He has a three.
Oh, okay, that's fine.
My rejected TEDx San Antonio talk will finally get the
recognition it deserves.
Sometimes reaching a certain point will have an effect like
this one, which will guarantee a fail.
Yeah?
Your team will fail this scenario?
Wait, what?
Mysterious.
fire is broken out at the refinery we got it under control
but we can't investigate the cause with all these dangerous
fumes flambay i would never blow up a refinery okay they
smell like someone oh too much will fail oh okay so no
combat oh that's hard oh hell yes oh this is bad me really
okay
Oh, this is bad.
Um...
I'm your guy.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I've messed up.
I think if I send in...
Oh, I'm a little bit too combat-oriented.
I guess I send in my all-rounder.
I have to send in my all-rounder.
there oh we're done a good job though
do i send in do i send in golem or malvola we're not sending
phenomena man golem or melvona which is better all
right i'll send in golem buildings would randomly blow up yo
man warden the hallways oh golem in last i forgot about that
i forgot about golem in last lot look if you wanted to grab
dinner all you had to do is ask.
Are you?
Oh my no, no, no, no.
Oh god.
Okay.
You're not my type.
I forgot about the slot.
That's the nicest thing you've ever said to me.
That's okay.
I think Golem can solo this.
Alright, I don't learn my lesson.
I don't learn my lesson.
I keep putting him in.
Okay, we got... Okay, now we can't keep putting on combat.
Okay.
Mobility.
I think he's smart enough.
Alright, Golem.
I believe you got this.
Oh god.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Oh!
Something about this feels off.
We're so close.
That was so close.
He did not guide.
It was rigged from the start.
Oh my god.
like every time we see beef he gets food maybe he's got an
iron stomach do we know anybody like that super digestion
the gluttony but oh they're trying to figure out who the
superhero is a thousand pounds hey robert did you recently
lose like 700 pounds first off you're either at math or you
think i'm like 300 pounds i am not i go to the gym and i
work hard secondly what are you talking about there's a pool
going around on which superhero this does not sound like
aaron paul at all
He sounds so serious so mature Could be house just one hint
I mean my friends right I was blue.
I was blue What if he was blue what does that mean wait we
we sad?
Yes, but it's just a coincidence.
Oh, come on.
Don't be like that Sorry, you're just gonna have to earn
nine hundred and thirty six dollars in some other way what
way could that be?
I'll let you know if I work it out Did it?
I'm explaining the joke.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Decent reflexes?
Hey, beef, no!
No, no coffee!
Do you know that talk too much and have quick reflexes?
Clean this shit up.
Hey, losing all that weight don't make you better than us!
Hey, yeah!
Shut up, Dad.
I never had a dad.
Aw.
I know.
Fuck that's supposed to me.
I mean...
Told me one time you didn't have a dad.
Huh.
I mean, it's sort of obvious a little.
She definitely looks like she has daddy issues.
heard the team scuffling with the red ring they run half the
crime in the county we were bound to bother them at some
point watch yourself you poke the hive you're gonna have to
fuck the queen that's not how bees work you know what i mean
i don't actually no one's trying to fuck shroud yeah he's a
taken man you would do that kill shroud yes you might get
the chance you don't want to go in there having to think
about it No hesitation.
Shroud killed him, Chase.
There's only one thing I can do.
You know that's not true.
I'm not sure your dad would want it that way.
You're not sure.
Should we ask him?
Should we ask a dead man that died to him?
I know Batman.
Mecha man's coming back to life one patch at a time.
One patch at a time.
I mean, Roy's doing most of the work, though, right?
So much.
this shit yeah heroes do kill the good ones so maybe if we
maybe because we kept letting these villains go we keep
having so much crime folks welcome back we got a few guests
actually like leading one right now is blue balls man
actually like for this business model we shouldn't be
killing villains i understand let me we have to let just let
them go just so we we can have more subscribers.
Yes, his power is not being able to nut.
No, his balls are literally blue, dude.
Get your head out of the gutter.
Great.
Oh, he's sick.
Why is Goldham sick?
Yeah, I'll be out of business if I keep killing villains.
Mr. Cat is all there.
It's so scary.
So, please find my boy.
There's a known escape I was in very fast.
He hates most people.
Okay, I have fast here.
I'll put two.
Okay.
What?
Did we just lose power?
What's the fuck?
What happened?
Citywide, hang tight.
We're booting up the backup generator.
There we go.
Hey, Robert.
Just brace yourself.
What?
Why?
Oh, shit.
Oh, you all can't see?
There's going to be a lot of people are going to ask for
help now.
close your eyes before yeah same i mean i can see in the
dark so this is pretty standard for me all right you guys
the whole city's out guys this is an all hands-on situation
okay i'm gonna get a grid back up and running be ready oh
this is gonna be a lot of stuff yeah there's gonna be a lot
of people some real action oh okay lots of hacking now
restart the power okay it says low difficulty but last time
someone tricked me about that Okay, I'm not timed, though,
which is good.
Wait, what?
Oh, okay.
Oh!
Okay, I get it.
Okay, I'm, like, funneling energy back to people.
Okay.
Oh, I see.
Oh, this is smart.
Okay, I think I have to do this one.
okay and then I grab energy here I like this this is a neat
concept and then I funnel energy here and I grab energy here
mr.
hacker man and then bam there you yeah that's an easy one
yeah like how there's a lot of variety in these hacking
games yeah that's a I've lost contact with the tower and
it's pitch black out here.
I cannot land this thing help Oh don't worry, it's the plane
on the ground Sounds dangerous.
I got flyers Oh Oh, never mind.
I don't got flyers
You're hurt, but oh yeah, you're you're so hurt wait
actually I got you you know what all in also heal him what's
a hell of a deal it's fine we don't need flyers they cannot
fly and yet they attempt to oh there was a choice it's fine
flying fucking slaps can you blame them for trying but their
feeble bodies were meant for gentler activities such as
walking and I knew it there you go open portal yeah exactly
I told you guys.
The danger.
I don't need no flyers.
I suppose their futile efforts to become more than they are
is admirable.
Okay, my mother lives in the senior community.
She hasn't answered the phone.
Go door.
Be prepared to provide medical assistance.
I think she can, he can do that.
Wait, okay.
What?
Oh, I don't know.
I don't know.
I'll think about it.
Actually, I think...
My mother lives in the Parkwood senior community.
And she hasn't answered her phone.
around there.
There you go.
Yeah, I know the elderly love you.
Your depression.
They see you and they'll be less depressed.
Can you lend a hand?
Preferably a strong one.
Any delays will cause another explosion?
Oh, shit.
Oh, god.
Okay, we'll think about that later.
Hello.
My baby brother ate my mommy and dad.
Calm the superpower, baby.
Rescue the parents out of the...
Oh, okay, I need all of that.
Huh?
Okay, we're gonna rest a little bit.
Don't worry, we have time to figure this out.
Oh my god, what the fuck do I do?
Gotcha.
Wait.
Oh.
Oh my god, why did I go all- It's fine, I believe in her
Everything happened in a blackout Mostly, like, bad shit,
though God damn it, the red ring stealing shipments Right
off the train We're not equipped to stop them Red ring Fuck
them up We just gotta do all...
Okay, I can't...
I have an idea Go there!
Oh.
What's it going to be this time?
Okay, her I'll crack some skulls
Yeah, it's fine.
Damn.
It's like dark and shit out here.
Uh...
Uh... Okay, we'll see what we get here.
Nice.
I knew it.
I've always believed...
Okay.
Secure defeat the Red Boons.
Okay, depression, man.
Mal.
I know a secret.
What?
Would you care to keep it?
Oh, shit.
Wait, yeah.
Let's go.
I don't need to keep a secret.
Alright.
Strangely, that's not the first time I've heard that.
Alright, at least the hacking is not timed this time, for
real.
I think I used my brain.
Alright, here.
We'll grab the passcode.
Alright, guys.
Remember this passcode.
Up, down, up, left, right.
Up, left, right.
Okay, and then...
Put it here.
Up, left, right.
And then...
Grab this.
There you go.
Got a double.
Up, left, right.
There you go.
Easy!
God, I'm such a good hacker, man.
No, you killed him.
and you're just the same villain being Satan and medieval.
Thank you for the super chat.
Oh!
Oh, I made it.
Nice.
Yeah, I knew it.
Golem, why can't you do that?
Golem!
Why could you do that?
Vandals are defacing the Torrance Library mural.
Hurry and catch them before there are peens everywhere.
Stop the...
Catch the preteens?
Okay, he's fast.
Right.
Not the penises.
It's a house of not...
knowledge calm the angry okay oh god oh no that's bad
okay all right that's good i was gonna say thank god all
right we might be oh we might be a little here because we
don't have enough intelligent
theme so um i'll put intellect in golem so oh
i'm looting the ralphs you want anything no um you only
stick with quarter in the dark i was about i need to do the
coffee i was trying to get coffee
Oh I'm so sad
Oh That's awkward.
Oh, that's so awkward.
I Will grab charisma.
I don't think we need more right now we can grab charisma
and then We'll also grab charisma here too.
We've got a situation that Ben labs.
They told me to call SDN.
I'm just an intern.
Oh.
Bro, my all of them are so strong.
They're all I must excuse myself.
You're depressed again?
Again.
Okay, who's the least strongest?
I guess Golem?
I think Golem is the only one I could do.
Okay, we're gonna have to do Golem.
I'm heading downtown.
See you can use some help.
Feel free to send someone.
I work better alone.
Alright, he's actually the only one.
Do me?
Fucking wrong.
Okay, do we...
Act quickly.
Okay.
Mobility.
Alright, we got that.
Oh No, why don't we have backup generator city what's the
taxpayers money for?
Okay Yeah It's fine Oh
What the fuck happened?
Oh, did I destroy it?
Oh That's right get out of here Get out of here Zap zap
Nearly there Okay Let's go okay we had to do this All right,
it shocked him Zap zap
All right, I Don't need a wait What did you do?
is on xp or whatever can reveal number slots and crime types
on hover for certain cause before they happen no i'll just
grab the double xp i think double xp seems a lot better
we've got several looting's in progress and our guys are
getting overwhelmed looting a team and oh basic bitches out
here where's the originality ah shut up it's like the go-to
black hat activity the candles your aunties i don't know
what apprehend the thieves do i need to be fast i don't
think i'll just be fast unless we get double yeah you know
what all right that's fine jesus christ
oh yeah me i guess okay sure yeah man i got a bad headache
right now it's that's why this one's a little bit why did it
say 10 intelligence
There we go.
There's no way I need any intellect for this.
There's no way.
Can I at least keep the guys responsible?
There's no way I need any brains for this.
I swear to God.
Oh, God.
Come on.
Sonar.
And Phenomenal.
I'm sorry.
It was fucking depressed.
I'm fighting him.
I have 10.
You don't even need to say it.
Fuck these guys up.
There's no way.
I was gonna say it.
I have 10.
I went all in on combat.
Yeah, I'm making you an all-rounder.
I have too many stupid people on my team.
I can't rely all on him because sometimes he changes to a
dumb guy.
Search and rescue.
I don't know what search and rescue would be.
That's the thing.
Okay, thank God.
10, 10, 10.
You sure we don't work on commission?
Wait for a man?
Everybody should step back.
She's slowly returning.
Oh, there's so many people.
My daughter was at the beach with her friends.
And I haven't heard from her.
I'm really worried.
Uh...
We'll do him.
You are quite an intimidating specimen.
Oh, God, okay.
On the outside, sob to the inside.
I believe that is how all life forms are.
Yeah, I meant like metaphorical.
I messed up.
A metaphorical dog.
Where?
Fresh as a daisy.
You don't need to see shit to punch shit.
Oh, yo.
It's fine.
Everything's fine.
I'm putting more intelligence in here.
I need more smart people on my team.
It's fine.
I have time.
I can get Prism in here.
Yeah!
Okay.
Hey girl.
And we have synergy too.
I think this shift gave me carpal tunnel.
See, look at that.
Oh, okay.
Where should we search guys?
Probably a combo type deal.
search the pier beach or what oh yeah thank god he's normal
too water no sign of them where else should we go beach oh
he could oh my god it was intelligence and charisma are you
fucking kidding oh he's she's dead she's dead
No, she's dead.
We are not.
Um, we...
I did not know!
Oh, yeah, no.
No, we're not.
She's not coming back.
How is I supposed to know?
You need intelligence.
I thought we were searching someone.
Be cool.
Don't do drugs.
Go to school.
school kids oh my god i could be wrong i fear the teenagers
were mocking me uh well you're not exactly cool man
impossible my body temperature is always proper oh my god i
said like the two non-cool people you're so right
all right let's see combat uh i'll put you in combat I can't
go on Not like this Just because a couple of teenagers made
Oh no, that's true No, never mind No, it's understandable
No, teenagers are really mean people No, I get it I I get it
Why no more combat I'm calling Nothing is up combat Imagine
more combat Kids are cruel.
They're so mean.
It's working.
Bringing a heal back from down.
Oh, nice.
Wait, they never really... Oh, I guess I can bring him back
from depression.
Charisma.
Who needs more charisma?
Maybe...
That's right.
More charisma.
Let's go in 13.
Anyone but sonar.
I'll go give it to sonar.
Good week, everybody.
See you all on Monday.
I mean, the sardines of Villambar, not sure I'd fit in.
Just go dress like that.
Everyone will just think you're a pervert.
What?
Yeah.
All right.
Oh, we're hitting it with the boys.
Let's go.
Oh.
Oh, this looks like a very non-villain bot.
Oh, look, he has his airpods on.
Damn big.
Oh.
You want to drink?
Sure.
Oh, that sucks, man.
Hey, creep.
Creep.
I don't know you, and I don't like not knowing people.
Well, you won't like knowing him.
He's the biggest perv west of the LA River.
And he's with us?
She's joking.
I'm not my business, but if you do go jerking off in the
bathroom, you make it my business That's um, I don't want to
be in that business Wait, this is a villain bar?
How the fuck are we the villain bar after being heroes?
Is there no hero bar?
No, there is a hero bar I guess it'd be cheaper too.
I feel like also that's so Stupid.
Why the fuck are they so...
Can they not just get arrested?
Like...
I guess they need a warrant to be in the villain bar.
Buy me a drink.
Oh yeah.
No, but my...
But they don't know my secret identity.
I got my Sour Patch kids on our first date.
I figure whiskey makes sense for the second.
She called it a day.
You can buy me dinner.
Nothing too fun.
I had a good time.
Yeah, it was fun.
I hadn't been to the movies in a while.
I had a good time.
Yeah.
popcorn too loud while i sat silently next to you the
silence was the best part i forgot them they got banned
sometime was that about sex get done quick i'll grab us a
table yeah because i see a mega man got banned but not
robert robertson make it three oh my god you black forever
this i recognize the bar We should have avoided him earlier.
He thought he was a fucking knock.
I recognize the spy.
He said he reminded me of my ex and he's got buzzkill-ass
energy.
Been doing this live?
How long have you been going out like this?
Since day one?
Don't act surprised.
You were the bad guy until...
Wait, when did we decide you wasn't the bad guy?
Yeah, when did we decide that?
I'm here.
Excuse me.
What do you mean, temporary blinded?
Bitch, you blind forever.
I'm thankful that our breakup has given me time to learn
about myself unfortunately what I've learned is that I hate
me oh good be honest am I going to make a fool of myself if
I sing Whitney Houston are you Whitney Houston no yeah you
will who be with drink for you wait it's kind of hard for me
but look I I know it was probably a by the books bottom line
kind of decision but thanks no problem you're gonna win 2025
hurry of the year bro we're gonna break the cycle we
need him to break the cycle guys
Oh, shit.
Everyone thinks I'm a narc.
They can still smell the hero on you.
You're the enemy.
What about depression then?
What else do they want?
You can buy him drinks.
You can make sure they don't get fired.
You can line him up and blow him one by one, but they're
still gonna think you might be the hero that fucked up their
life.
People don't think about much when I blow him.
But I hear what you're saying.
argue they fucked up their own lives being criminals see
that snark shit just tell him he's a loser any of them
anyway he's a loser so it's fine bro
I must have died during this fight if he's having PTSD I'm
not done with you Yeah
What the fuck is a neck that I do that's valuable bro
Oh shit, oh Oh,
I didn't even notice that
I have no leaves And I need it OP And it doesn't even
function anyway Cause I have your actual dysfunction It's so
catchy guys I thought they lost it working in a deli or
something And there was this incident in crypto Where he was
fucking with me And I kind of I've been dealing with that
wistly ass tooth Cause of you Well it was self-inflicted But
I'm not sure he'll see it that way So you can see Why I'm
worried about getting in That's how catchy it is.
Oh, yeah, because he doesn't know.
He doesn't know you get it over with.
He doesn't know it's met the man.
Sooner we get a fresh start.
You heard me when I said incinerated, right?
Who let a loser ass bitch of a hero into our supervillain
bar?
Why is everyone?
Do I look like a bitch?
Don't answer that.
Is he big?
He's got big guy voice.
Some parts of him are big.
All right, from now on, team drinks are exclusively at
Chili's.
Are you lost or something, bitch?
Or you're trying to get fucked up.
What happened to his arms?
Why is it?
A lot of bars around here, fool.
Why'd you pick this one?
You got a death wish, homie?
Well, since you twisted my arm.
No one's talking to you, fucking you.
I see they finally gave you some arms that can reach your
dick.
There's some people that want to talk to you, if it's a
bitch.
That's a good one.
What?
Why are they all glowing red?
Oh, there's, like, argumentations?
Did all these guys have the same argumentations?
Yeah.
Try this.
Thanks.
What the fuck?
How did they all get hit?
I am happy to provide these inauthentic Mexican calories for
the team to reach off to after that.
Oh, is that the red ring gang?
Did they all have to...
xbox get a red ring oh jesus charlie triple crunch tacos
they're all buffed by shroud oh my god my oh
wait why was that censored
she temporarily blinded me You mean temporarily.
Bitch, you blind forever.
She said to lie.
No, I didn't order that.
I ordered three tacos.
Three triple crunch tacos.
Yeah, you muttered it 50 times.
Just eat that.
It's the same shit anyway.
You blind forever.
This place is just a remix of the same five ingredients.
Hot sauce?
Say it alive, boy.
I'd go with both.
Or do some friendly fire.
Fuck you mean temporary blinded.
forever oh they all united with their x-box getting the red
ring of death
haha sorry board oh shit
you wash your hands after touching all them filthy nutsecks
salty oh there she is thanks waves source it up for me and
everything thank you looking for these oh there's the crunch
tacos the special move there you go oh bro bro that's some
strong ass teeth that's a strong fucking just doing some
sugar you know
Is there a fucking penis drawn there?
Just so you know, super into this.
You're all gonna love this.
That's what I'm saying.
Why can't I fucking romantic?
Oh shit, now you enjoying.
Yeah, that's right.
oh my god rip the arm rip it rip it yeah oh oh you should
just rift it both arms y'all are fucked up weird thing is
how easy it was this churro isn't as soft as his noodle arms
yeah his arms are just like tiny next time you want to
heroes know heroes don't start fights you finish them oh
that's so corny well not many finished fights against the
red ring yeah how do you have beef with them mr dispatcher
yeah we know this robber guy is affluent who are you really
i'm robber it's a rare thing in life you know fresh start
clean slate you all know every room you walk into your
reputation for proceeds i walked into sdn and suddenly i was
me it was just me big decision i'm robbie two months ago two
months ago yesterday why no i saw the other options i just
want to be robbing right now i'm robert dokey no that was
that was a big decision tactic who are you i just told you
you're the heroes now what what do you mean it was the first
thing i i went instinct what's your problem i don't like not
knowing things that might make me mad if i knew them i'm
robbie just let it go bro be free i did it was me commander
robbie and i was like i'm
Chad it's such a it's a big choice hi Chad um my name's
Courtney look see we're all doxing ourselves now look it's
so cute was the name given to me on my planet when I first
arrived on earth the ladies at the Nordstrom rack I worked
at called me dumpy due to my large posterior wait really you
may call me either my name's victor because i'm a fucking
winner i'm alice bruno ah malevolah my last name's gib my
name's column so what now orgy time right make a fuego sauce
and ass play sounds like a great combo good point anybody
had another packet of that style like everyone's like
biggest decision right now and i'm like i'm ravi I just want
to be robbing
Look see Everyone's happy guys Everyone's so happy
Yeah Sounds like hip hop but it's not Yeah
It's like a run DMC.
You know, they came through a wall, but this is different
song.
I hate the world today.
You're so good to me.
I know that I can change.
I can't change.
Yeah, you can change.
I'm trying to tell you, but you look at me like maybe you
won 17%.
Oh, that doesn't sound great.
I just want to be rapping.
It's so so soft.
I back up sing for me.
I can understand how you could be.
Oh chase doing still shout Okay, but like do you want to
watch the same playthrough of someone not being robbing or
you will watch the 17% Send the ground team save the
Terrence Held your own against yay I have no dreams and a
tiny little ping and it doesn't even
Yeah.
Rest assured that when I start to make you nervous and I'm
going to extremes.
Tomorrow I will change and today won't mean anything.
Thank you.
Thanks for playing Doki.
I really enjoyed watching you play Dispatch.
This is my first ever super chat.
So it's only right to go to my first ocean.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, go.
I'm glad you guys have been having a fun time watching.
I'm going to have to call it, call it here, though.
I actually have to call it here now.
But we did do a lot.
Oh my gosh, I'm going to listen to the next episode just for
instinct.
Don't worry.
We will complete it.
We will complete it next week.
We'll complete the last three episodes next week.
But thank you all for watching.
I've been having a really fun time playing.
dispatch.
I hope my playthrough has been very enjoyable so far with me
with me being rabid.
I'll take you with a super chat.
Thank you.
I'm glad you're playing this game.
It just lets me know what not to do.
Thank you with a super chat.
Thank you.
So I know I know there's three more episodes so we will
finish it next week.
Maybe on Tuesday.
We'll do it either Tuesday or Monday.
Thank you all for watching, everyone.
I am going to get my third monitor fixed up now.
Well, not...
Well, I have a third monitor, but I'm going to go install my
third monitor after this stream.
Hey, Jakarta.
Thank you.
Here's to Robert.
That was a very fun way to enjoy my birthday weekend.
I can't wait for the next one you play.
Dispatch.
Think of a super chat.
Thank you.
Greg, thank you.
A super chat.
Thank you.
Doki, you're an itch, and your name is Robert.
You gotta live with this.
Thank you, my super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Patre, I said, thank you, my super chat.
I knew you wouldn't make the correct choices to piss off
everyone in chat.
You are the best donkey to ever punish.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What do you mean the wrong choices?
These were the choices that vibe with me the most.
I thought they were great choices, guys.
I thought they were wonderful picks.
for the most interesting experience guys we're not here to
do like the same gameplay that every the same gameplay the
boring goody two shoes decisions we're here to do things
that are fun
anyway as always everybody say hydrated posture check get up
and move around and get that blood flowing and if you suffer
me head to bed cause you deserve it i'll see you guys next
time everybody Paul, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
With huge voter turnout in the chat, we should petition for
a phenomenon sonar romance path as downloadable content full
of non-stop huggies.
Surely did.
Man Pat will win three of the year.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's what I'm saying.
Why can't I romance?
This is the perfect harem game, I would say.
I swear if season two does not give me a harem, then they
learn nothing.
This game, have been so much more popular and we could have
romanced everyone in our team why does he have to be a
hundred percent straight he could be a little bit curious
that's all i'm saying like being surrounded with all these
superheroes and super villains i mean so true you could be a
little curious i mean what's that game The Dungeons and
Dragons game.
That was that one game of the year.
Everyone loved that game because you could romance everyone.
That's why it was so popular.
I swear to God, if that game doesn't restricted the
romancing, the game would not have one game of the year,
chat.
Baldur's Gate.
If Baldur's Gate 3 restricted who you could romance, it
would not have one game of the year.
I should be allowed to romance everyone Hey guys, I'll see
you guys later everybody Bye guys Bye